Und ich bin ein Zollstock.
Ja.
So, das größte Chaos ist beseitigt. Wir sind einigermaßen in Sendeklauf, diesem kleinen Schiff hier in Potsdam. Nochmal herzlich willkommen zum Blumon. Mein Name ist Mec Warbeck, der tut aber heute Abend nicht so richtig viel zur Sache. Denn es ist ja der letzte Mittwoch im Monat und das heißt Chaos Computer Club ist angesagt. Es gibt heute eine kleine freundliche Einweisung in das fröhliche Hackerleben. Deswegen sind auch ganz viele Menschen vom Chaos Computer Club hier im Studio, nämlich Andreas, Felix, Jan und Frank. Wenn ich jetzt von all denen noch mal kurzes... Hallo, hier ist Jan.
Andreas bastelt gerade noch an irgendwelchen Computern. Er kann nicht Hallo sagen, aber kommt er noch.
Also wenn der Fritz einen Senderausfall hat, Andreas ist schuld.
An den Klang der Mikrophone arbeiten wir noch ein bisschen.
Genau, und auf jeden Fall auch noch mal ganz herzliche Grüße an Johnny, weil Johnny fort gerade, er spawned sozusagen und ist deswegen auch nicht hier.
Ja, ich sag vielleicht noch mal so ein paar Basics vorweg zu dieser Sendung. Ihr könnt an dieser Sendung mehrfach virtuell digital teilnehmen. Zum einen sind wir per Stream live im Netz unter www.fritz.de slash isdean.ram oder auch dasselbe mit slash modem.ram. Oder ihr könnt auch in unseren WeChat reingehen, einfach unter www.fritz.de und dann nicht den Freestyle-Chat nehmen, sondern den V-Chat reingehen und dann werdet ihr auch dort betreut. Und wenn ihr das Ganze denkt, ihr könnt es nicht zu Ende hören, das Ganze ist total toll auch morgen als Real Audio noch vorhanden und ihr könnt euch die Sendung dann noch mal anhören. So, jetzt aber, vielleicht Frank sagst du mal ein paar einleitende Worte und vielleicht auch ganz kurz noch was zu euch.
Ja, wir sind alle vier vom Chaos Computer Club und Hacker klingt immer so ein bisschen blöd zu sein, gibt man immer nicht so gern zu. Wir wollen heute Abend ein bisschen was erklären, wie man den so hackt. Nicht wie man hackt, sondern was es so für kleine Hilfsmittelchen gibt, sozusagen kleine Handwerkszeuge, um das Leben leichter zu machen, dass man ein bisschen auf Datenreise gehen kann. Das heißt, dass man sich mal andere Systeme angucken kann, und mal schauen, was da so drin ist oder vorne weg steht und wie auch immer. Wir werden jetzt am Anfang so ein bisschen das Grobe erklären, dass ihr so ein bisschen so den Überblick habt, worum es hier geht. Und im zweiten Teil werden wir dann unser Spielchen erläutern. Das heißt, ihr könnt nicht nur im Chat teilnehmen, sondern könnt auch mal richtig mitspielen bei uns. Wir haben ein kleines Spiel vorbereitet. Wir hoffen, dass das alles so gut geht mit der Technik und im Internet. Das ist ja mal so ein bisschen schwierig. Dann werden wir ein bisschen was über Angriffsmöglichkeiten erzählen, welche Tools es so im Einzelnen gibt, welche kleine Programme man da nehmen kann. Dann im dritten Teil werden wir ein bisschen was über verspannte Systemadministratoren erzählen. Das heißt, wie die so reagieren, wie sie vielleicht nicht reagieren sollten.
Verspannte heißt in diesem Fall ein bisschen schlecht drauf.
Ein bisschen schlecht drauf oder auch ganz gut drauf, je nachdem und was da so passieren kann, wenn man da ein bisschen zu fahrlässig und zu grob drauf loshackt.
Und nebenbei gibt es natürlich auch für euch die Gelegenheit, zu Hause das Telefon zu ergreifen, Fragen zu stellen, die Sachen, die hier gesagt werden, zu kommentieren oder vielleicht auch eure eigenen Erfahrungen zum Besten zu geben. Das wird richtig großartig. So, dann kommen wir doch mal zu dem eigentlichen Thema des heutigen Abends. Ja, Tools, Werkzeuge. Wollen wir da gleich richtig mit ins Eingemachte gehen? Können wir auch. Marton steht hier an den Reglern und spielt eine Platte nach der anderen und mixt sie auch für uns hier. Also erstmal statt Daten Müll, Sound Müll.
Nein, nicht.
Schöne totale Daten hier jetzt vom Mixer. Kann da jemand von euch mal an den Mixer hacken bitte? Der Chaos Computer Club am Mittwoch, dem WeChat ist schon Regelteiligung, könnt ihr euch weiterhin einloggen. Und jetzt geht's ins Eingemachte.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir vielleicht erst mal klären, wovon wir eigentlich reden. Also eigentlich sollten wir uns diese Hacking versus Cracking Definitionsgeschichte nicht weiter einlassen. Also manche Leute verstehen unter Cracking das Beseitigen von Kopierschutz, andere Leute verstehen unter Cracking das Eindringen in den Rechner. Wieder andere verstehen unter Eindringen von Rechner hacken. Andere Leute denken hacken sei schreiben von Programmen. Vergessen wir das Ganze. Es geht heute um das über das Netzwerk Rechner dazu bringen, Dinge zu tun, für die sie nicht programmiert wurden.
Doch programmiert schon, bloß nicht erlaubt zu tun.
Was denn nun genau?
Genau, wir wollen jetzt erst einmal gucken, was...
Na erlaubnis ist immer schwierig. Also ich würde sagen, wofür sie nicht gedacht waren. Das ist lustigerweise auch die Definition für erfolgreiche Software, dass man damit Sachen machen kann, die der Autor nicht im Sinn hatte. Deswegen ist alles so ein bisschen zweideutig in der Szene.
Richtig, also der Begriff Hacking ist schon ziemlich weitläufig. Wir wollen heute versuchen, vor allem die Sachen, die übers Netz gehen und auf, sag ich mal, fremde oder auch eigene Computer gerichtet sind, um da einfach zu schauen, was da drin steckt, was dahinter steckt, was auf den Systemen läuft vielleicht. Man kann da Leute natürlich auch noch auf arge Sicherheitslücken aufmerksam machen nebenbei.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen, was motiviert jemanden fremde Rechner anzuzapfen und zu gucken, was da läuft, anzugehen? Was motiviert euch das zu tun?
Na, bei den meisten Leuten Langeweile, bei uns, wir sind natürlich die Guten. Also wir machen das, weil wir den Leuten sagen wollen, dass sie ein Sicherheitsproblem haben. Und der Nummer eins Grund ist neben Langeweile halt, dass man sich kein Fortbilden möchte. Also viele Leute haben das Bedürfnis, Sachen zu lernen und das kann man am besten tun, indem man ausprobiert. Und dabei werden dann eben Sicherheitsprobleme gefunden, da werden natürlich auch normale Bugs gefunden, eben Softwarefehler. Aber es werden auch Sicherheitsprobleme gefunden, das sind einfach ganz normale Bugs, die sich aber ausnutzen lassen, um Sachen machen zu können, die man eigentlich nicht machen sollen dürfte auf der Maschine.
Wenn man irgendwo in der Zeitung lesen kann, dass wieder irgendein Rechner gehackt worden ist, meinetwegen die Homepage vom weißen Haus oder sowas verändert worden ist, dann liegt das oft auch an der Nachlässigkeit der Betreiber, dass sie da irgendwas falsch konfiguriert haben, irgendwas falsch eingestellt haben. Manchmal liegt es natürlich auch an fehlerhafter Software, wobei man natürlich auch fehlerhafte Software auch erkennen kann. Oder wenn bekannt ist, dass die fehlerhafte Software unterwegs ist und im Einsatz ist, dass sie dann nicht rechtzeitig beseitigt wird, dann kommen natürlich auch mal Leute, die sowas ausnutzen. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt hacken in dem Sinne, sondern das ist dann das Anlegen oder das Benutzen von Exploits, sogenannten Exploits. Das sind also diese Programme, die schon gefundenen Sicherheitsblicken ausnutzen, um einen unberechtigten Zugang zu einem Rechner zu kriegen.
Also das ist auch ein Teil dieser Sendung. Also diese Tools, die Wertzweige, die man raucht und dann die Exploits, sind dann ein Gegenteil oder ist das was anderes?
Das ist dann die weiterführende Sache. Also wenn man erstmal die Tools benutzt hat, um halt rauszufinden, wo der Rechner angreifbar ist, dann benutzt man die Exploits, um dann halt dort weiter zu spielen, Spaß zu haben. Oder halt...
Lässt sich das irgendwie an einem Beispiel sagen, wie das funktioniert, als wenn man jetzt meine Reaktion an ein Werkzeug benutzt hat und dann beispielhaft mit einem Exploit weitermacht?
Ja, ich lege da jetzt vielleicht mal mit fachbegriffen los, man nimmt einfach einen Scanner, einen IP Scanner, setzt den auf einen bestimmten Adressbereich an, zum Beispiel auf meinen Internet Provider, aber das macht ihr so, don't try this at home. Also, das ist ja auch noch so eine rechtliche Problematik, was das Hacken angeht, das wird ja oft nicht so gern gesehen. Sei es so, man könnte zum Beispiel von irgendeinem Rechnernetz, am besten vielleicht von dem zu Hause oder einer Firma, wo mir der Chef vorher das okay gegeben hat, dass ich da hacken darf, nehmen wir jetzt mal den Idealfall. Dann probiert man mal aus, welcher Mail-Server da läuft zum Beispiel und dann stelle ich fest, das ist dann der Coupop sozusagen, da gibt es dann halt ein Programm, den nenne ich Coupop und dann weiß ich, aha, kann ich im Netz suchen, Fehler, Coupop, aha, gibt es einen, übersetze ich auf meinem Computer oder lasse es laufen und zack, schon bin ich da. Habt ihr sozusagen die Systemverwalterechte, also die sogenannten Root-Rechte. Das ist also praktisch immer oder meistens das Erstrebte, was ich dann haben will, wenn ich so einen Rechner aufmache, dass ich also Root bin. Root ist also bei Linux, äh, bei Unix allgemein. Es ist der Super-User, das ist also derjenige, der vollen Zugriff auf das System hat, der absolut alle Rechte hat auf dem Rechner.
Den hier versucht auszutricksen.
Das ist der, den man versucht zu werden.
Also auszutricksen tut man ja eigentlich nur Menschen, oder Software eben, aber was man nicht auszutrickst, ist eher eine Rolle. Also ist die Programmrolle, die alles darf. Und das ist auch eine der Hauptbeschwerden an Unix-Systemen im Laufe der Zeit, dass wenn man dieses Ziel erreicht, dass man dann alles machen kann, und da gibt es inzwischen auch Bemühungen, da eine genaue Sicherheitsaufteilung zu machen, dass ein User eben dann nicht alles machen darf. Also Ruth darf zum Beispiel auch die Platte einfach direkt lesen und da irgendwelche Dateien kopieren. Noch eine Sache zum Chat. Beim V-Chat könnt ihr nicht nur mit euch selbst reden, sondern auch mit uns. Und im Moment glaubt mir das gerade einer nicht. Ich bin der Felix, der da Chat als Fefe ist. Also macht da keinen Scheiß im Chat, wir sehen das alles.
Ja und Lutz Straub freut sich glaube ich auch gerade. Der ist nämlich auch schon wieder drin. Okay, jetzt haben wir die Tools vs. Explosor, gibt's nachher in der Sendung. Geht ihr noch ein bisschen näher drauf ein, was man da zum Beispiel benutzen könnte und stellt auch ein paar Sachen vor. Cracking vs. Hacking haben wir schon erklärt, was so ein bisschen der Unterschied ist.
Aber es ist eine Diskussionssache, denke ich, da kann man eine eigene Sendung drüber machen.
Gut, Andreas hat ja kurz einklingen lassen, also lassen wir weg. Trojanische Pferde.
Trojanische Pferde, ja. Trojanische Pferde ist ein kleines Programm, was man jemand auf den Rechner schleust und was dann Informationen nach außen liefert.
Das, was meistens noch eine sinnvolle Beschäftigung tut, in sinnvollen irgendwas macht, aber im Hintergrund halt böse Sachen macht, die eigentlich nicht beabsichtigt werden.
Das berühmteste, berühmt berüchtigste Programm mittlerweile heißt Back Orifice von Cult of Dead Cow. Das haben mittlerweile richtig viele Leute auf ihren Windows-Rechnern und viele davon wissen es gar nicht. Und damit kann man ganz, ganz viel rumspielen. Da kann man den Rechner komplett kontrollieren, steuern, Dateien und Späten auslesen.
Das heißt also, wenn ich zu Hause einen Rechner habe und ich kriege meinetwegen E-Mails und bin auch am Internet angeschlossen und jemand hat mir so ein trojanisches Pferd reingeschleust, kann der sozusagen meine E-Mails alle zu sich umleiten, sie lesen oder sonst irgendwas.
Ja, kann nicht nur die E-Mails, sondern alle Dateien. Er kann auch einfach die, die gesamte Testkarte erfüllen. Zum Beispiel die Schublade vom CD-ROM-Laufwerk auf und zu machen, die Maustasten vertauschen, wobei das noch die harmlosesten Sachen dabei sind.
Ich glaube, das ist bei mir kaputt. Also das ist wahrscheinlich kein sorianisches Werk.
Ich finde, das ist einer der großen Vorteile bei Windows-Rechnern, wenn man irgendwelche Windows-Leute angreift, dann denken die normalerweise, wenn irgendwas abstürzt oder irgendwie die CD aufgeht, dass sie dann ein Hardware-Problem haben oder dass es eben Windows-Schuld ist. Aber das ist das Letzte, was man glaubt. Und das passiert auch echt in Profis. Also es gibt da ganz nette Stories, wo vielleicht nachher noch zu kommen werden. Da kann man viel Spaß mit haben. Es ist besonders lustig bei Unis. Es gibt so manche Unis, die haben Multimedia-Labs, wo dann eine Webcam daneben steht und da kann man den Leuten eben zugucken, wie sie reagieren, während man da so die CD-ROM raus schlusst.
Und das ist immer ganz nett. Also diese Werkzeuge, Tools, Exploits, damit umgehen kann und auch weiß, was so trojanische Pferde sind, ist man dann sozusagen schon so ein Vorleufer zum Hacker? Oder braucht man da noch mehr?
Hacker ist auf jeden Fall dann, wenn man sich für alles desinteressiert. So eine Sache und da immer weiter nachfragt, sich nicht mit einfachen Antworten abgibt, sondern wirklich nachgucken will, was genau da passiert. Das heißt, wenn man so volles technisches Verständnis dafür hat, was da geht, und es alles auch reproduzieren kann und auch selbst anwenden, ohne irgendwelche Exploits zu benutzen am besten. Das heißt, wenn man das alles behandeln machen kann.
Also wenn man ein Programm startet und in der anderen Rechner stürzt ab, dann ist man noch kein Hacker. Wenn man weiß, warum der andere Rechner abstürzt, dann ist man ein Hacker.
Na ja, auch noch nicht. Also eigentlich ist man erst dann Hacker, wenn man selber mal einen Exploit geschrieben hat und wenn man genau verstanden hat, was das Problem ist, wenn man am besten der Erste ist, der das Problem verstanden hat und dann ein Programm schreibt, was es ausnutzt. Aber da gibt es halt nicht viele von und deswegen alle wären gern Hacker. Also wir können ja vielleicht bei der Stelle auch mal sagen, der CCC hat eine Mailing-Liste, wo man von außen Fragen hinstellen kann und die Nummer eins Frage ist halt, wie kann ich Hacker werden? Da freuen wir uns immer, schmeißen das weg und wenn derjenige sehr persistent ist, wir haben da neulich jemanden gehabt, der hat, ich glaube, wie viel, 20 Mails oder so, der hat einfach überhaupt nicht Ruhe gegeben und irgendwann fragen die dann, sag mal, reagiert ihr nicht auf mich oder mögt ihr mich nicht oder so? Also ja, wir mögen euch nicht.
Wie lange habt ihr gebraucht, um solche Werkzeuge euch anzueignen, damit so fit zu werden, dass ihr wirklich Ebenen erreicht, wo das richtig Spaß macht?
Also das fängt eigentlich schon im Kindesalter an, wenn man den Videorekorder verstanden hat.
Also braucht man lange? Ein Jahr, zwei? Oder muss man da einfach mehrere Nächte durchmachen?
Man muss einfach Computer leben, glaube ich, wenn man das richtig zu verstehen.
Man muss auch erst mal Grundlagen wissen, was nicht besonders klein ist und wenn man das Grundlagen wissen hat, kann man vor allem irgendwelche Manpages lesen, also die Manuals dazu. Und da ist eigentlich meistens alles halbwegs gut erklärt, dass man das dann auch verstehen kann.
Vor allem Hacken ist einfach auch eine Lebenseinstellung. Hacken ist nicht eine Tätigkeit, sondern Hacken ist eine Lebenseinstellung. Das System muss man haben, so eine Grundeinstellung, einfach immer noch mehr interessiert sein an allem und noch mehr nachfragen und nicht lockerlassen.
Ist das auch dann mit so einer Zielrichtung nachher wieder in so einer halbwegs legale Kiste zu kommen, damit auch Geld zu verdienen oder ist das für euch gar kein Ziel mehr?
Na ja, so Kommerzhacken, da gibt es auch sehr geteilte Meinungen drüber.
Genau, es gibt in Amerika so ein Movement, da gibt es Leute, die sich bezeichnen als White-Hat-Hackers. Also es gibt da immer Andeutungen aus Militärjargon und aus irgendwelchen Geheimdienstfilmen und White-Hat heißt immer in weißer Hut. Das heißt, das sind dann nicht die Leute, die mit dem schwarzen Schlappu drum laufen, sondern mit dem weißen. Das sind also die Guten. Und sie behaupten also, das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, weil man kann ja nicht wissen, ob jemand wirklich hacken kann oder nicht. Das heißt, wenn jemand zum Geheimdienst geht und sagt, ich bin jetzt einer der Guten und es gibt auch immer wieder Leute, die sagen, ich bin deswegen gut Herr Hacker, weil ich beim CCC bin und das ist auch ganz gern benutzt. Aber letztendlich nachprüfen kann man das nicht und deswegen Firmen sollten nicht irgendwelche Hacker einstellen, ohne vorher sich zu überlegen, wie sie nachprüfen, ob der nicht bei ihnen vielleicht ein trojanisches Pferd installiert. Das gibt es alles vorgekommen.
Und die lege ich mir feuern, die Leute, weil dann kommt garantiert ein.
Okay, was meint ihr, wenn die Leute jetzt drei Stunden lang zuhören euch? Wie weit sind die dann vorbereitet fürs Hackerleben?
Wir haben erst nur noch zweieinhalb Stunden.
Also ich denke, es sollte auf jeden Fall auch keine abschalten, auch wenn es vielleicht ein bisschen manchmal sehr technisch wird und wenn ihr da eigentlich nicht mehr so mitkommt, dann ist es gar kein Problem, aber dann wisst ihr ja, warum ihr kein Online-Banking mehr macht und warum ihr eure Daten nur noch über verschlüsselte Verbindungen des Internet benutzt.
Am besten zeichnet das auf oder ladet euch nachher das MPEG runter davon und hört euch das in drei Jahren nochmal an, wenn ihr richtig Ahnung habt und dann versteht ihr auch irgendwie alles oder auch nicht.
Die große Wissen des Datenbank in Form des Chaos Computers. Heute hier, okay, ich schätze mal, nach dem Info können wir dann auch langsam loslegen, Fragen zu beantworten. Wenn Leute oder auch eigene Erfahrungen können hier eingebracht werden.
Genau. Und ihr könnt auch schon langsam mal eure Internetverbindung anschmeißen. Und dann nach den Nachrichten gibt's bestimmt die API-Adresse aufgeschlüsselt.
Stimmt, ihr habt auch so kleine Aufgaben vorbereitet, sozusagen das Einmal-Eins für Anfänger, Heckanfänger.
Einfach halt mal den Spaß auszububilen.
Genau, alles austesten. Und dann geht's unter 931 77 97 110 auch hier telefonisch weiter. Im Studio Andreas, Felix, Jan und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club. Noch zweieinhalb Stunden hier sind auch erreichbar per Computer im Budget. Wir haben hier natürlich auch die schönste Nebensache der Welt völlig in Griff, nämlich Fußball. In Barcelona sind zurzeit 88 Minuten gespielt, hier steht immer noch 1 zu 0 für München. So, mittlerweile 22.30 Uhr.
Kurz Info.
Nimmst du das große Mikro bitte?
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Wir haben es vorne umgestellt.
Ja klar, kommen wir nochmal an.
Machen wir nochmal. 22 Uhr 30.
Kurz Info. Kriegsverbrecher. Jugoslawiens Präsident Milošević soll nach US-Informationen noch in dieser Woche vom UNO Kriegsverbrecher Tribunal in Den Haag angeklagt werden. Danach sollen ihm voraussichtlich Kriegsverbrechen im Kosovo zulasst gelegt werden. Der Haftbefehl ist bereits unterschrieben, hieß es weiter. Strategie. Die NATO hat ihre Luftangriffe auf Ziele in Jugoslawien und im Kosovo auch heute fortgesetzt. Gleichzeitig ging die Vertreibung der albanischen Bevölkerung durch serbische Einheiten weiter. Bei den Kosovo-Gesprächen in Moskau zwischen Russland, der EU und den USA zeichnete sich noch kein Durchbruch ab. Der russische Sonderbeauftragte Tschernomyrdin forderte die NATO erneut auf, ihre Angriffe auf Jugoslawien einzustellen. Absicht. Bundesgesundheitsministerin Fischer hat ihren Gesetzentwurf für die Gesundheitsreform vorgestellt. Kern ist ein festes Ausgabenbudget von 250 Milliarden Mark jährlich. Das Gesetz wird von der Ärzteschaft und der Pharmaindustrie kritisiert. Einschränkungen, die Ansiedlung weiterer Fabrikverkaufszentren am Stadtrand von Berlin soll in Zukunft nach Möglichkeit verhindert werden. Darauf haben sich heute die Länder Berlin und Brandenburg in der gemeinsamen Landesplanungskonferenz verständigt. Wetter. Nachts gering bewölkt oder klar um 6 Grad tagsmeist. Sonnig, Höchstwerte bis 27 Grad.
Verkehr.
A10 westlicher Berliner Ringen von Dreieck Haveland in Richtung Dreieck Werder zwischen Dreieck Haveland und Falkensee, Vollsperrung nach einem Unfall. Der Verkehr wird in Richtung Dreieck Haveland an der Anschlussstelle Falkensee abgeleitet. Das Dreieck Haveland ist in Richtung Dreieck Werder voll gesperrt. Kraftfahrer werden gebeten, den Bereich weiträumig zu umfahren.
Dumme Sache dies. In der 91. Minute schafft Manchester United den Ausgleich.
Ja, ja, ja.
Resentiers, einen Wettbewerb im Internet.
I wanna see it.
Denkmal 2. Online gegen Gewalt, Rechtsextremismus und Fremdenfeindlichkeit.
Mit Workshops, Reisen und einer Internetgalerie für eure Beiträge.
Denkmal 2.
Online gegen Gewalt, Rechtsextremismus und Fremdenfeindlichkeit.
Alles im Rahmen der Aktion Tolerantes Brandenburg. Alles was ihr dazu wissen müsst. Wie auf den Webseiten von Fritz. www.fritz.de Denkmal 2.
Der Blue Moon am Mittwochabend mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Mein Name ist Mac Warbeck, tut aber hier nicht zur Sache. Andreas, Felix und Jan und Frank, das sind hier die Professionals, die Ahnung haben. Sag Hallo zu den Leuten, haha. Werkzeuge, Tools, das ist das Thema des Blue Moons hier heute Abend. Kleine Einführungen haben wir in der letzten halben Stunde schon gegeben und wenn ihr dazu jetzt Fragen habt, könnt ihr unter anderem anrufen. Und derweil werden Frank und Konsorten weitere Geschichten vorstellen zum Thema.
Genau, hacken als Sport, wollen wir mal ein bisschen was erzählen. Es gibt den Begriff Hacksport und wir hatten vom Club letztes Jahr, irgendwann, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wann es war, hatten wir ein sogenanntes Deathmatch. Das ist also ein Spiel gewesen, ein kleiner Wettkampf, wo vier Rechner waren mit Linux drauf, in einer sogenannten Out of the Box, also gerade frisch von der CD installiert. Und dann ging es darum, diese Rechner so weit fertig zu installieren, dass das Netzwerk läuft und dass bestimmte Services drauf laufen. Das heißt also, dieses Ding musste irgendwie zum Mail verschicken geeignet sein. Man musste seine Mail abrufen können, ein Web-Server sollte laufen und noch einen FTP, also einen FTP-Programm. Dann ging es darum, diese Services sozusagen am Laufen zu halten, dass der Rechner alles das tat, was er so zuverlässig tat, was er tun sollte. Und es hat einen Game-Server kontrolliert. Das war also ein Programm, der lief da und hat die ganzen Services jeweils mal abgetestet bei dem Rechner, bei den Spielrechnern, bei den Wettkampfrechnern. Und dann ging es darum, dass sich die Teilnehmer, die Spielteilnehmer jeweils in Teams zusammengesetzt, dass sie sich gegenseitig den Rechner aufhaken sollten. Ja, und dann ging es los, nachdem erstmal fleißig die Netzwerkkarten konfiguriert werden, mehr oder weniger erfolgreich, ging es dann los mit irgendwelchen Portscans und Packet-Sniffing und den ganzen Spielereien.
Kannst du da ganz kurz für mich als Line im Nebensatz einflächeln? Also was macht man damit mit diesen Spielereien?
Mit diesen Spielereien versucht man erst mal so ein Grundwissen über den Rechner zu kriegen. Normalerweise weiß man auch nicht mal, was da für eine Kiste steht.
Also Sniffing, gleich Schnüffeln, gleich erstmal...
Schnüffeln, Sniffing bezeichnet man das, wenn ich mich in das Netzwerk mit reinhänge, wo der Computer drinne steht und sozusagen alles mitschreibe bei mir auf dem Bildschirm oder auf der Festplatte, was über das Netzwerk geht, also komplett alles. Es gibt verschiedene Ebenen, wo man sniffen kann. Die übliche ist, dass man sozusagen den Internetverkehr, also das alles, was über das Internetprotokoll läuft, mitschreibt. Manchmal kann man das auf bestimmte Services, wie zum Beispiel Passwörter für die Mail oder... Ich glaube, bei diesem Deathmatch hatten wir glaube ich, das war das erfolgreichste oder das Wichtigste, diese Mail-Passwörter mitzusniffen, weil damit hatte man auf jeden Fall schon mal einen Zugang zu dem Rechner und konnte darin weitermachen.
Man sollte das vielleicht ein bisschen erläutern, weil die Leute haben immer falsche Vorstellungen zum Sniffen. Also Sniffen heißt nicht, dass ich hier mit meinem Rechner in New York irgendwo Netz abhöre, sondern ich kann immer nur das lokale Netz abhören und das funktioniert auch nicht bei allen Medien. Also es funktioniert zum Beispiel nicht bei Frame Relay oder ähnlichen Verbindungen, die nur zwei Punkte connectieren. Also das funktioniert bei Ethernet zum Beispiel, Ethernet ist halt sehr verbreitet, ist also limitiert in der Anwendung. Man müsste also, wenn man in der NSA irgendein Netzwerk mithören wollen würde, dann müsste man dort in diesem Netz auch einen Rechner hacken und dann könnte man mit horchen. Es gibt allerdings noch andere Möglichkeiten, die ein bisschen gefährlicher sind, die allerdings mit Hacken erstmal nicht zu tun haben. Also man kann durchaus Abstrahlung messen von Rechnern, die irgendwie über das Stromkabel rausgehen, die kann man dann aus dem Haus abnehmen, das ist so Geheimdienstniveau. Aber was uns als Hacker interessiert, ist natürlich das Sniffen an sich. Das heißt, man hat tatsächlich einen legitimen Zugang zu dem Netz. Das ist besonders einfach an Unis, wo man mit seinem Rechner reinläuft und dann ist gut mit seinem Laptop. Und dann kann man eben zugucken, wie die Leute sich einloggen und dann hat man gleich 100 Accounts. Das ist Sniffen. Das ist allerdings nicht sonderlich sportlich. Das heißt, das macht man vielleicht mal, wenn man irgendwie Langeweile hat oder sonst gar keinen besseren Angriff findet. Oder eigentlich greift man auch nicht an, um irgendwas kaputt zu machen oder um sich Accounts zu sichern.
Genau, und für die Profis unter euch wollen wir jetzt gleich mal loslegen. Schmeißt mal euer Internet an und tipp mal in euren Podscanner die Adresse Playground.linuxsecurity.de Das ist also Linuxsecurity in einem Wort. Playground.linuxsecurity.de Oder über numerische IP-Adresse die 195.222.228.123 Nochmal 195.222.228.123 Könnt ihr auch im Chat noch mal nachfragen, weil hier alles werden wir noch ein paar mal sagen. Und an diesem Rechner sollt ihr euch einfach mal versuchen.
Der steht jetzt, also wisst ihr wo der steht?
Genau, der steht in Hamburg. Das ist also ein Freund, Kollege von uns, der hat hier freundlicherweise Verführung gestellt.
Der steht bei der Deutschen Bank im Keller.
Und das wäre auch super freundlich von euch, wenn ihr nur genau diesen Rechner irgendwie versucht anzugreift und keinen anderen, nicht die 124 und auch nicht die 122, weil es vielleicht besser klingt hinten.
Und keine Brennstäbe rausfahren bitte.
Und auch bitte irgendwie nicht www.linuxsecurity.de, sondern bitte genau diesen Rechner, weil alles andere könnte irgendwie Ärger geben und das wollen wir ja nicht.
Ihr Besitzer meint auch schon, das wird erst geschossen und dann gefragt.
Genau. Also wie gesagt, auf diesem Rechner habt ihr unser Okay, da dürft ihr jetzt eure Wut oder euer Kreativdrang oder ein Stilchen auslassen.
Könnt ihr das hier irgendwie verfolgen? Also seht ihr jetzt, was da passiert? Gut, also ihr verfolgt das jetzt, wie der Rechner da gerade gecrashed wird. Wenn mein Bildschirm jetzt hier schwarz wird, dann war das der falsche Rechner.
Dann hast du euch in der Nummer vertippt.
Weil dann war das www.crashed.de.
Crasheden soll er ja nicht. Also ein Rechner zu crashen, man nennt das eigentlich den Nile of Service Angriff. Und worum es ja eigentlich geht, ist den Rechner nicht nur runterzufahren, sondern den Rechner unter seine Kontrolle zu bringen.
So, dann sind die Leute mit dem Spiel beschäftigt.
Genau, vielleicht können ja die, die da erfolgreich irgendetwas festgestellt haben, uns anrufen, von ihren Erfahrungen berichten.
Genau, unter 031-7797-110. Michael hat angerufen und hat eine Frage zu Win95.
Nein.
Michael?
Also, ich habe da eigentlich auf eine der Fragen beziehungen zwischen Win95 und Win95. Also, ähm, ich weiß nicht, ist Win95 wirklich so schlecht?
Ja, es ist komplett schlecht. Aber wir haben uns heute Abend eigentlich vorgenommen, kein Betriebssystem-Bashing zu machen.
Ja, wir machen Ausnahmen. Wir sollten vielleicht mal die Regeln verkürzen, wer anruft und eine Windows-Frage stellt, wird gleich rausgekickt oder so, weil sonst wären wir hier nicht fertig. Wir haben noch zwei Stunden.
Es ist einfach so, dass Windows nicht irgendwie Sicherheitsmerkmale aufweist, im Groben. Also, bei Least 5 mache ich darum jetzt mal schon wieder irgendwie Linux in Vorderrunde. Wir haben uns eigentlich echt vorgenommen, das zwar nicht zu machen, aber es bietet sich an, zum Beispiel BSD oder Linux.
Aber Michael, du hattest auch gefragt, was der Vorteil ist von Linux, oder?
Ja, also ich habe gehört, dass ich irgendwie so viel sicherer werde, und ich habe jetzt auch geplant, so langsam auf Linux umzusteigen, aber ich weiß nicht.
Tu das.
Soll das irgendwie so schwer sein?
Ich habe auch keine Ahnung.
Es ist ja auch viel vorm Programmieren und so weiter.
Programmieren musst du nicht, aber Linux fordert dich ein bisschen heraus, dich mit dem Computer auseinanderzusetzen. Also bei Windows schaltest du an, klickst ein bisschen rum, und entweder geht es oder nicht. Wenn es nicht geht, dann hast du halt verloren, und bei Linux hast du die Möglichkeit, eben nachzugucken, was da vielleicht schief läuft. Also, du musstest dich schon ein bisschen einarbeiten, aber ich denke, du wirst dich auch ein bisschen mit dem Computer auskennen.
Ja, das ist einfach auch Linux, weil bei Windows klickst du halt einfach was an, und dann läuft es, und dann stellst du dir keine anderen Fragen.
Also ich hab letztens irgendwie die neuste Linux-Version von Susi installiert, und da hast du auch noch zweimal draufgeklickt, und dann hat das auch schon fast alles.
Aber du hast ja die Möglichkeit, dich tiefer mit dem Rechner zu beschäftigen, die hast du bei Windows einfach in der Regel nicht. Genau.
Gut, Michael.
Wir hoffen dir geholfen zu haben. So, und weiterhin könnt ihr anrufen unter 0331 70 97 11 12. Felix, du beobachtest den WeChat auf www.fritz.de. Was läuft da gerade?
Ja, na im Moment gibt es hier jemanden, der penetrant rumpfragt, wo ein Scanner herfindet. Also liebe Leute, wenn du nicht weißt, was ein Scanner ist, oder wenn du noch nie einen benutzt hast, dann frag auch nicht, weil du bist nicht die Zielgruppe.
Ja, meine Antwort dort ist immer, benutzt eure Suchmaschinen.
Genau. Also das ist die, das ist die Frage.
Was ist ein Scanner?
Ein Scanner ist ein Programm, der zu einem Rechner geht und einfach die Dienste ausprobiert. Also im Internet kann ich mehr als einen Dienst machen. So einen Dienst, den alle benutzen, ist Web, aber E-Mail ist ein anderer Dienst. Und man muss natürlich unterscheiden können, wenn ich zu einem Rechner eine Verbindung aufbaue, ist das jetzt E-Mail oder ist das jetzt Web? Und dazu gibt es eine Portnummer. Und da gibt es 65.000 noch was von. Und wenn ich jetzt einen Rechner nur vom Namen her kenne, dann ist das erst etwas, was mich interessiert, welche Dienste da überhaupt drauf laufen. Und dazu benutzt man einen Portscanner. Der geht hin zu dem Rechner und versucht alle aus. Es gibt dann noch bessere Methoden, aber das ist halt die grundlegende Methode. Der probiert einfach alle Dienste aus und guckt, auf welchen eine Antwort kommt.
Genau, das muss man sich ja so vorstellen wie, na nicht wie Schubladen oder so was, sondern wie passende Steckdosen oder ich weiß nicht, wie man das anders beschreiben kann.
Ein Roboter, der durch die Behördengänge läuft und guckt, welche Türen nicht abgeschlossen sind.
Ja, ja, genau. Wenn man Web benutzt, dann geht es über Port 80. Das ist irgendwie ganz bekannt. FDP ist Port 21. Mail ist Port 25.
Hier ist jetzt auch eine direkte Frage zu Werkzeugen.
Ja, zu Werkzeugen.
Von Christian aus Berlin.
Hallo, Christian.
Ja, hallo. Ich hätte eigentlich nur so eine Frage zum Thema E-Mail-Account. Also ich bin ehrlich, ich hab keine Ahnung von Computern.
Dann ist das hier glaube ich die falsche Sendung für dich.
Nee, aber frag ruhig mal.
Ja, das ist doch talentiell falsche Sendung. Ich hab mir bloß über Talknet hier einen E-Mail-Anschluss legen lassen.
Ey, ich denke du hast eine Frage zu Werkzeugen.
Ja, genau, da wollte ich gerade zurückkommen.
Du bist hier bei Fritz, das ist dir klar, oder?
Wie ich jetzt meinen E-Mail-Account irgendwann mal freigeschaltet kriege, weil die sagen mir jenseits, dass es nicht möglich ist, blablabla. Und dass ich erst mal was zurückschicken muss.
Ja, dann musst du das aber wohl machen.
Dann gehst du zum Vorwärter und musst auf den Tisch kotzen, wie immer, wenn du keinen Service kriegst.
Ich hab da zwei Mal angewiesen mit denen, hab da mächtig auf den Tisch gekotzt. Die haben immer nur gesagt, ich schick mir Unterlagen noch mal.
Was sollen wir denn da jetzt machen? Sollen wir jetzt zu deinem Servicevorwärter gehen, oder was stellst du dir vor?
Ich würde gerne mal nicht wissen, wo man blind ist, oder wenn wirklich günstiger ein E-Mail-Account kommt.
Na ja, kostengünstiger, wenn es dir nur um E-Mail geht, dann kannst du natürlich bei einem dieser kostenlosen E-Mail-Dienste was nehmen. Nein, wie zum Beispiel GMX. Ich glaube, GMX ist einigermaßen PC. GMX kann ich mit ruhigem Gewissen empfehlen, weil diese zu einem deutschen E-Mail-Account sind.
Gleichzeitig sollst du sagen, dass sie ziemlich langsam sein sollen.
Na, aber besser langsam als gar nicht, oder?
Ja, das ist genau meine Meinung gewesen. Andere Adresse habt ihr nicht?
Na, wenn nicht, wie der altgekannte Spruch, Suchmaschinen nach kostenlosen E-Mail-Adressen oder sowas.
Es gibt glaube ich www.email.de oder kostenlose E-Mail oder sowas gibt es.
Einfach ein bisschen rumschreien.
Ne, brauchst nicht mitschreiben, weil es nur geraten.
Probier mal ein bisschen rum. Einfach in eine Suchmaschine eingeben, Christian, ja? Also ihr merkt schon, mit so 0815 Fragen kann man hier echt nicht durch. Obwohl ich sie völlig berechtigt finde und auch schön, weil ich lerne dadurch auch extrem viel. Hier geht's jetzt zu einer ganz nette Frage. Lass uns die noch ganz kurz machen, Frank. Timo aus Klaasthalf-Tellerfeld fragt nämlich, ob er schon kriminell ist, was sie hier gerade erzählt habt.
Timo?
Hast du Bedenken?
Nö, ihr ruft ja dazu auf.
Also bei euch ist das sicherlich legal.
Aber wenn ich jetzt ohne Einverständnis dessen, den ich da scanne, irgendwie solche Aktionen mache, weiß nicht, kann er mich dann irgendwie belangen?
Dann ist das natürlich illegal.
Du kannst auf jeden Fall den Ärger kriegen.
Illegal ist relativ. Es gibt dazu noch keine gerichtlichen Entscheidungen. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, Portscan ist nicht illegal. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, Portscan ist illegal. Die Wahrheit ist wahrscheinlich irgendwo dazwischen. Wenn du mal irgendwo einen Portscan machst, dann ist das wahrscheinlich kein Problem. Wenn du über ein ganzes Glas B-Netz auf Port 635 scans, dann ist das wahrscheinlich schon eher ein Problem. Und letzten Endes hängt es davon ab, was du da nachmachst, ob es ein großes Problem wird oder nicht.
Also in Norwegen ist Portscan erlaubt.
Das ist so. Du musst dir das so vorstellen, als wenn du an einer Reihe von Autos vorbeigehst und bei jeder Tür probierst, ob sie vielleicht vergessen wurde, abzuschließen, ob sie offen ist. Ich denke, das ist ein ganz guter Vergleich.
Das heißt, wenn ich jemanden finde, der meine Rechner Portscannt, dann kann ich dem auch erstmal nichts anhaben, es sei denn, ich kann ihm nachweisen, dass er irgendwas Böses damit vorhat. Oder muss der wirklich was Böses tun?
Nein, in Deutschland ist schon Portscan nach Meinung von manchen Experten illegal. Das heißt, da kannst du mit deinem Anwalt mal reden und dann wird er wahrscheinlich erstmal für die Beratungen eine Rechnung stellen. Aber wenn dich das tatsächlich interessiert, sollst du das tun.
Aber es muss doch voll ist sein.
Also, ich kann mal sagen, als ich mal an der Uni gearbeitet hab als Administrator, haben wir einen Portscan gehabt und dann hab ich da eben angerufen bei dem Provider, der für diesen IP-Range zuständig war und hab gesagt, da ist ein Portscan, dann haben die dem halt seinen Account getötet. Ja, der hat mich gescannt, das darf man nicht.
Timo, hast du das Problem gerade?
Ich hab das ständig, ja.
Also Backorifice ist sehr beliebt.
Auf deinem Rechner oder dass du das mal probierst?
Auf meinem Rechner. Nur hab ich so einen Portfake gebaut, der sagt mir dann halt da und da, hat sich jemand an und an verbunden.
Den hast du selber gebaut oder den hat jemand anders gebaut?
Das ist ja trivial zu machen.
Naja, da gibt's nachher noch eine Story zu Fake.bo, was ganz lustig wird.
Ja ne, den verwende ich nicht. Das hier ist einfacher. Sagt halt dem ein.de, hau ich ja auf dem Port und wenn was kommt, dann find den, mach GetPierName und guck.
Du bist Administrator oder? Ja auch. Wir haben eigentlich im dritten Teil ein bisschen was über Administratoren, wo wir noch ein bisschen mehr dazu erzählen wollten.
Kannst ja vielleicht nochmal dann anrufen.
Vielleicht, ja, genau, dann passt das vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser rein. Weil wir wollten jetzt erstmal so ein paar grobe Sachen zu DCP anrufen.
Timo, eine ganz kurze Frage hab ich noch. Klaus Tatterfeld, gehörst du uns über den Real Audio Stream?
Also die Beschwerde haben wir hier im Chat auch stehenlich, aber wir können das von hier aus echt gar nicht ändern.
Es gibt ja auch dann noch einen MP3 morgen. Vielen Dank Timo. Weiterhin viel Spaß beim Flimmern und Rauschen in deinem Rechner. Okay, ein paar Fragen beantwortet, Frank macht weiter. Musik? Können wir tun dieses, ist nicht das Problem. Williomona, Mittwochabend, zu Gast ist der Chaos Computer Club und es geht um Werkzeuge, die man braucht. Viele Sachen zu machen. Spielen zum Beispiel.
Vielleicht sollten wir zu dem Spiel noch ein paar Worte verlieren, das ist glaube ich nicht ganz rüber gekommen. Also das Spiel ist sozusagen für die Leute, die schon sich auskennen mit dem, worüber wir hier reden, sozusagen für die Experten. Wir werden noch am Ende der Sendung wissen, was darüber erzählen, was da passiert ist. Und wenn ihr euch damit auskennt, dann hackt diesen Rechner. Playground.linuxsecurity.de Und hier on Air würden wir dann eher auf die grundlegenden Fragen eingehen, werden noch eure Fragen beantworten. Sofern sie irgendwas mit dem Thema Netzwerksicherheit zu tun haben, sind Sie willkommen.
Okay, Netzwerke haben wir hier auch. Unter 031-7097-1S0 könnt ihr euch einwählen. Oder ich sag's auch nochmal unter www.fritz.de könnt ihr auf den Widget nimm den Widget, der schneller, schöner, besser und da ist auch Felix dabei, der das ganze kontrolliert und auch Sachen beantwortet. Also er kommuniziert sozusagen.
Ich hab hier Spaß im Widget und übrigens kommt alle rein. Also hier ist mehrfach gefragt worden, ob wir einen ERC-Channel haben. Haben wir im Moment nicht. Also hatten wir früher mal, ist aber ersetzt worden durch Widget. Also wenn den Channel gibt's sicherlich CCC oder sowas, aber ist halt nicht das echte, das echte ist Widget.
Lohnt sich das eigentlich, einen Chat zu hacken?
Na ja, es gibt natürlich im ERC schon so Geschichten wie Channel Wars. Also es gibt ja im ERC normale User und Operator und Operator ist man immer in einem bestimmten Channel. Wenn man Operator ist, darf man die anderen Leute rausschmeißen und sowas. Es finden da durchaus Kämpfe darum statt, wer jetzt Operator ist, unter anderem auch mit schmutzigen Tricks, wie die Kleinst der anderen Leute zu flannen und so weiter und so fort. Und ist eigentlich auch interessant, haben wir uns aber nicht wirklich darauf vorbereitet. Ich glaube, hier ist keiner wirklich irksüchtig.
Gut, dann kümmern wir uns um die Netzwerke. Mario hat angerufen aus Potsdam. Hallo Mario. Mario, stelle deine Frage.
Ja, und zwar habe ich vier Rechner mit einem Netzwerk verbunden intern.
Da drüber über das TCPIP-Protokoll.
Und nun ist meine Frage, das Ganze möchte ich über DFÜ-Netzwerke auch noch benutzen. Dass ich mich übers Telefon einwähle und da kommt keine Verbindung zustande, sag ich mal. Also der Rechner wird nicht erfunden, die Verbindung wird aufgebaut.
Mario, hast du das Radio an? Mach mal bitte ganz aus, sonst gibt es hier eine fiesere Kopplung und ich brauche meine Ohren noch die nächsten 30 Jahre.
So, und jedenfalls kommt keine Verbindung zustande, also der Computer wird nicht erfunden, wenn ich ihn übers DFÜ-Netzwerk suche.
Von wo jetzt? Meinst du einen internen Computer oder einen externen Computer?
Die interne Verbindung haut hin übers TCPIP-Protokoll.
Ja, das heißt du kannst sie sozusagen alle anpingen, das ist immer so ein Test.
Und komme ich jetzt von außen mit einem anderen Rechner außerhalb, kommt praktisch die Verbindung zustande, aber der Rechner wird nicht erfunden. Also ich finde keinen Rechner.
Ja, ja, das liegt einfach daran, dass du von deinem Provider wahrscheinlich nur eine IP-Adresse kriegst. Du bist wahrscheinlich bei einem normalen Provider irgendwie.
Na, ich gehe direkt an. Also nicht übers Internet oder so, sondern direkt. Hab den Rechner als DFÜ-Saber eingerichtet und...
Naja, dann haut er da irgendwas mit diesem Routing oder Vorworting nicht an.
Dann solltest du vielleicht mal Linux zum Routen verwenden.
Nicht Windows einsetzen, Leute.
Hey, kein Windows-Patching heute.
Na, Windows haben wir denn sonst Patching?
Nee, aber ernsthaft, wir wissen wirklich nicht, wie man dieses Problem lust. Also unter Linux würde man jetzt in Warlock Messages nachgucken, was übrigens auch immer gut ist, wenn irgendwas mit dem Rechner nicht stimmt, weil da meistens relativ viel steht, was nicht stimmt. Dann würde er einem sagen, warum das nicht funktioniert. Und wie man dein Problem jetzt löst, wissen wir leider nicht.
Aber auf jeden Fall kannst du froh sein, weil nämlich andere Rechner können ja nicht von draußen aufgehackt werden, wenn sie nicht erreicht werden können. Es ist ein angenehmer Nebeneffekt davon.
Ich frage mich dummerweise nur wieder, warum du, Mario, aus Potsdam, einfach vier Rechner in deiner Wohnung hast.
Ein Floh, ein Wohnzimmer, ein nacktlicher...
Also jetzt beschreibe uns kurz deine Wohnung.
Ja, das ist eine ganz normale Einzimmerwohnung.
In jeder Ecke ein sozusagen.
Eine Einzimmerwohnung und vier Rechner?
Naja, im Keller ist auch noch was.
Was für die Mäuse?
Was steuert der Rechner im Keller an?
Na der soll als Server dienen, wo ich mich außerhalb einwählen kann.
Gut, Mario. Pass schön auf, dass niemand dich killt da und hackt. So, eine weitere Frage kommt. Und jetzt geht's auch um Protokolle. Alex aus Ludwigsfelde hat angerufen.
Ja, ich wollte mal, hätte mal eine Frage zu dem Protokoll ICMP. Ich habe mich gerade damit ein bisschen wenig beschäftigt. Und mir sind die einzelnen Services, also die auf TCPIP basieren, da ist mir, also die Sicherheitslücken, die sind alle geschlossen bei mir, würde ich sagen, jetzt so von meinem Stand aus war. Aber da ich weiß, dass in verschiedenen Großrechnernetzwerken das Protokoll ICMP zum Anpingen der Rechner durchgelassen wird, durch jeden Firewall, wollte ich mal fragen, ob das häufig verwendet wird, um die Exploit zu erzeugen. Das heißt, Pakete hin schicken zu den Rechner, boom, du bist unten, so ungefähr. Das wollte ich mal wissen. Oder ob das wirklich nur auf die Ports geht?
Nein, also es gab mal einen ICMP-basierten Exploit, nämlich ein Teil von Ping konnte benutzt werden. Genau, Ping of Death, aber das war es eigentlich auch schon und das Firewalls Ping durchlassen in irgendwelche internen Netze. Also wer sowas macht, der hat keine Gnade verdient insofern.
Ja, ich kenne mich so hin. Naja, ich kenne im Prinzip nur ein Rechnernetzwerk, wo das nicht durchgelassen wird.
Dann solltest du bei den anderen mal schnell hingehen und irgendwie Consultingdienste anbieten. Haben die nämlich dringend nötig.
Will jetzt noch jemand Smurf erklären?
Vielleicht mal ganz kurz ICMP. Internet Control Message Protocol. Das heißt also, wofür nimmt man das genau? Man versucht, wenn ein Computer jemand einen anderen Computer erreichen möchte, dann schickt er dann erstmal so eine ICMP-Message. Und guckt, Felix guckt mich hier ganz zweifelhaft an. Also es wird in der Praxis dazu benutzt, um festzustellen, ob ein Rechner da ist, ob er funktioniert, ob er Netzwerkanschluss hat.
Ja, dafür wird ping benutzt. ICMP kann allerdings auch andere Sachen machen, wie zum Beispiel, wenn auf dem Weg im Internet irgendwo festgestellt wird, der Rechner, den ich eigentlich erreichen wollte, mit meiner Webverbindung, der ist gerade runtergefahren, dann wird mir mit ICMP mitgeteilt, dass der ganze Rechner weg ist. Oder, was auch geschehen kann, ist das sagen kann, dieser Rechner irgendwie, also man kann so 2, 3 Kontrollnachrichten machen. Es gibt auch sowas wie Netzwerk Discovery, also man kann den Router fragen, wie die Netzmaske aussieht mit ICMP. Da gibt es einige obscure und weniger obscure Sachen. ICMP benutzt wirklich jeder irgendwann mal. Das merkt man nicht. Also auch Windows hat ICMP zum Beispiel. Also alle Leute, die TCP machen, haben auch ICMP, weil da Kontrollnachrichten über verteilt werden. Aber es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt sagen kann, ICMP ist ein Protokoll, über das ich auch web machen kann oder über das ich irgendwo eingreife. Es gab halt einmal dieses ICMP-Ping-Problem. Prinzipiell werden über ICMP eigentlich keine Nachrichten, außer einem einfachen Status, wie dieser Rechner ist jetzt tot übertragen. Also keine Datenübertragung wie bei FDP oder so.
Aber deine Hauptsorge war jetzt, Alex, ob das Ding sicher ist, oder?
Ja, eben.
Willst du mal ausprobieren? Sollen die das mal hacken?
Wir können hier im Chat mal die IP-Nummer sagen, aber...
Nee, ich hab keine statische.
Schade auch. Nein, Ping hat man glaube ich auf jedem Rechner, der TCP-IP-Netzwerke hat. Also auch bei Windows gibt es das. Dann könnt ihr einfach mal an der Eingabe-Aufforderung oder an der Manuselle eingeben, ping, P-I-N-G. Und dann eine IP-Adresse, zum Beispiel eure eigene oder auch die von eurer Lieblingswebsite, um zu gucken, ob die denn noch da ist.
Es gibt natürlich tatsächlich mehrere Exploits, die auf ICMP basieren. Zum Beispiel gab es das berühmte Ping of Death. Und zwar wurde da ein ICMP-Ping-Paket erzeugt, das länger war als die vorgeschriebenen 64K. Und beim Zusammensetzen dieser 64K hat zum Beispiel das beliebte Betriebssystem Windows nicht darauf geachtet, dass der Buffer übergelaufen ist und ist abgestürzt. Und ja, dann gab es noch Smurf. Smurf ist eine Möglichkeit, den Traffic, den man erzeugen kann, von einem Rechner aus zu vervielfachen. Man schickt ein speziell konstruiertes Ping-Paket hin, das so tut, als käme es von der Netzwerkadresse von einem Netzwerk. Und die Antwort darauf geht dann an das ganze Netzwerk, das dann darauf wiederum reagiert mit das habe ich aber gar nicht abgesendet. Und man kann also mit einem Paket, je nachdem wie viele Rechner da sind, bis zu mehreren hundert Paketen erzeugen und mit seiner Modemleitung eine komplette 2 Megabit-Leitung dicht machen. Also auch das ist ein Grund, um SMP nicht durchzulassen auf der Firewall.
Also der größte dokumentierte Fall von einem Netzwerk, das Smurf-Problem hat, hatte über 24.000 Rechner.
Alex!
Kleine Zwischenmeldung. Der Mensch, der von der HU Informatik auf den Rechner hackt, es gibt da kein R-Share, ganz sicher nicht.
Alex, was mich jetzt am Rande noch interessiert, warum bist du so besorgt um deinen Rechner, um die Sicherheit darum?
Nö, weil mich interessiert es einfach. Ich will zwar auch an den Rechner hacken, aber in erster Richtung. Erstmal so ganz langsam anfangen, ganz langsam. Aber ich will aber gleichzeitig meinen Rechner auch schützen.
Alles klar, also du sorgst schon vor für dein späteres Leben.
Aber eine ganz kurze Frage, gibt es noch ein anderes Protokoll, außer direkt TCP, IP, was aber direkt vom Colonel beantwortet wird? Denn TCP kann man ja durch den Rapper, das wird ja standard demis bei Linux durch den Rapper rausgefüllt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Also da bringst du ein paar Sachen deutlich durcheinander. Also erst mal TCP wird genauso vom Colonel gemacht wie alle anderen Sachen, weil der Colonel genau die Abstraktion bietet, dass ich eine Verbindung aufbaue. In Wirklichkeit habe ich nämlich keine Verbindung, sondern ich schicke einfach Pakete raus und kriege Antwortpakete und konstruiere daraus anhand eines Protokolls eine Verbindung. Aber TCP Rapper ist ein User Space Programm, was du eigentlich meinst, sind Firewalls, die nämlich sozusagen im Colonel Pakete rausfiltern, die bestimmte Ports betreffen. Und unser Moderator macht hier gerade sehr lustige Verrückungen.
Ich wollte noch Frank bitten, den Fernseher auszuschalten. Das nervt, Schatz.
Nein, also prinzipiell, alle Protokolle werden erstmal vom Colonel behandelt, die auf TCP-Ebene sind und alle Anwendungsprotokolle wie FDP und so werden vom Colonel an User-Programme weitergegeben, an Server-Prozesse. Letztendlich, natürlich, man kann sich IPX oder so angucken. Da gibt es natürlich auch so Sachen, die direkt von Colonel gemacht werden. Aber das ist auch, man könnte theoretisch auch einen FDP in Colonel einbauen. Und bei NFS ist das zum Beispiel geschehen, bei manchen Herstellungen. Also letztendlich, da ob nun Colonel oder nicht, ist an der Stelle nicht weiter relevant eigentlich.
Alex! Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Eine Minute nach 11, ich sag nochmal ganz schnell. Mit Merck Wapik und dem Chaos Computer Club. Ich sag nochmal schnell für alle Bayernfans, ihr müsst traurig sein. Mensch, das hat 2 in 1 gewonnen und ist dann mit Champions League Sieger. So, damit habt ihr das Thema Fußball auch abgehakt. Chaos Computer Club zum Thema Tools, zum Hacken. Ihr könnt das Ganze verfolgen im Widget unter www.fritz.de oder wenn ihr jetzt schon eine Stunde versäumt habt. Gar kein Ding, weil morgen als Real Audio oder MP3 bei uns im Netz. Oder ihr könnt das Ganze auch, wenn ihr jetzt gerade in Richtung, was weiß ich, Polen oder sonst wo fahrt, einfach als Livestream auch bei uns im Netz mithören, das Ganze. So, wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen dichter auf diese Protokolle eingehen? Da gibt es eine ganze Menge. Und vielleicht auch noch mal so ein bisschen allgemeiner sagen, also wovor braucht man diese Protokolle so im Allgemeinen?
Genau, also ich wollte erst mal kurz erzählen, dass der Server, dem es zu hacken geht, der heißt nochmal playground.linuxsecurity.de oder 195.222.228.123. Ja, erklär doch mal jemand, ihr könnt es bestimmt auch besser, was TCP ist. Wie funktioniert eine TCP-Verbindung oder wozu braucht man, was ist TCP? Was heißt TCP ausgesprochen?
Ja, TCP ist der Dienst bei der Protokoll Suite für Internet-Protokolle, die Verbindungen aufbaut. Und natürlich sind Verbindungen nur so eine Definitionssache. Letztendlich, was passiert auf der bloßen Leitung ist, dass ich da Datenpakete absetze. TCP funktioniert so, dass man zur Verbindung aufbaut. Schickt man ein Paket hin, hallo, ich möchte eine Verbindung aufbauen. Dann kriegt man eine Antwort zurück von dem Server. Okay, Verbindung kann aufgebaut werden. Und dieses beantwortet man nochmal mit einem Paket, was sagt okay. Und damit steht dann eine TCP-Verbindung für den Körner. Wenn einer der Rechner dann verschwindet, dann sieht es für den Körner nach wie vor so aus, als wenn die Verbindung besteht. Also das ist rein Anschauung, ob jetzt da Verbindung ist oder nicht. Das sieht nur für den User so aus. Letztendlich ist die Verbindung nach wie vor paketorientiert. Und wenn man dann ein Stück Daten verschicken möchte, dann wird das aufgeteilt in Pakete. Es gibt da pro Leitung eine Maximalgrenze, wie groß das größte Paket sein darf, was darüber verschickt wird. Und wenn man jetzt mehr Daten verschickt, dann wird das eben aufgeteilt in kleinere Pakete. Und da schreibt man dann rein, was man übertragen möchte. Und der andere Rechner beantwortet dann, dass dieses Paket erfolgreich angenommen wurde. Und da gibt es jetzt noch zwei, drei Performance-Tweaks, dass man den Server nicht einfach sagen lässt, ist angekommen, sondern bei seiner Antwort schickt er unter anderem in dem Paket einen kleinen Teil mit, der sagt, ist angekommen. Also dass man nur eins statt zwei Pakete verschickt. Sowas gibt es noch, aber so prinzipiell läuft das so.
Es geht ja hier auch um Sicherheit. Kannst du kurz sagen, bei TCP, wie ordnet man das ein? Also wo sind da Schwachstellen?
Ja, TCP hat protokollbasiert ein paar Schwachstellen, die einfach von der Konzeption drin sind, gegen die man auch nicht viel tun kann. So zum Beispiel, dass bei den meisten Medien, die benutzt werden in Netzwerken, man die Quelladresse einfach einstellen kann. Das heißt, ich kann einen Rechner ins Netz klemmen und von dem aus ein Paket abschicken, was behauptet, von einem anderen Rechner zu sein. Und weil das alles eben paketorientiert ist, kann ich vorher mir angucken, wie denn die Verbindung zwischen den beiden Rechnern aussieht. Da werden sogenannte Sequenznummern ausgehandelt, die benutzt werden, um zu erkennen, ob das ein Paket jetzt früher kam, als das Paket, was in der Sequenz davor gewesen wäre. Und wenn man diese Nummer gesehen hat, oder man kann die auch manchmal raten, dann kann man von anderen Leuten die Verbindung übernehmen, indem man als der andere Rechner Pakete abschickt. Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger zu erklären. Da kann man aber mit seiner Suchmaschine die genauen Problemstellungen erklären lassen. Aber das liegt am TCP-Protokoll, dass das vorausgesetzt wird, wenn jemand von dieser IP-Nummer ein Paket abschickt, dass der dann schon diese IP-Nummer sein wird. Das verursacht einfach Probleme, die unter anderem TCP betreffen.
Genau, dann gibt es noch UDP, das ist User Datagram Protokoll. Und das nimmt man, wenn man Sachen, wie soll man das sagen, Sachen los schicken will, die vielleicht nicht so wichtig sind. Kann man das so sagen?
Nö, eigentlich nicht.
Also die, die, es gibt keine, aus Performance-Grund, das heißt, es gibt also keine Flusskontrolle, sondern man schickt was los und geht mal einfach davon aus, dass es ankommt, so wie man es abgeschickt hat.
Also vor allem hat man das, wenn man mit TCP eine Verbindung aufbaut, dann muss man auf die Antwort von dem Server warten und muss dann nochmal ein Paket hinschicken und dann steht die Verbindung erst. Das kann ein paar Millisekunden dauern oder wenn man eine lange Leitung hat, kann das schon mal länger dauern. Das heißt, besonders für irgendwelche Videokonferenzen oder Telefonie über Internet benutzt man eigentlich keinen TCP aus dem Grund, sondern UDP-basiertes.
Aber kann man das so vergleichen wie telefonieren und einen Brief schreiben? Telefonieren heißt das in einer TCP-Verbindung, die verbunden ist. Heißt, da weiß ich, merke ich auch, dass der andere noch dran ist und irgendwie eine Postkarte oder einen Brief verschicken. Die schicke ich halt los und die ist dann morgen oder vielleicht auch erst übermorgen da oder auch nicht, wenn der Briefträger sie verschlammt hat oder so.
Ja genau, prinzipiell so. Also man kann sagen, UDP sieht so aus, dass ich mich auf einen Marktplatz stelle, an der anderen Seite steht der, mit dem ich reden will und da schrei ich halt los, hallo und der hört mich halt oder nicht und TCP sieht so aus, dass ich zudem eine Handyverbindung aufbaue oder sagen wir mal einen Kabel lege, das ist dann doch mehr an der Analogie dran und dann kann ich eben direkt mit dem lesen, äh mit dem sprechen.
Protokolle. Protokolle, genau.
Na gut, das sind jetzt die User-Protokolle. Die sind für Sicherheitsuntersuchungen, ist das dann eine andere Ebene?
Genau, Ebenen halt, das müssen wir erklären, das Schichtenmodell. Das ist einmal eins oder sowas, der Netzwerktechnik, das gibt also sogenannte Schichtenmodell, das USI heißt das meist, USCI Schichtenmodell. Es gibt verschiedene Ebenen, wie die unterste Ebene, also das physikalische Medium, das ist also meist das Kupferkabel, sei es jetzt das Ethernet-Kabel oder vielleicht auch die Telefonleitung. Dann kommt da drüber, beim Ethernet zum Beispiel, das Ethernet-Protokoll. Dann geht es weiter mit IP, richtig?
Na, IP ist nicht direkt nach dem Schichtenmodell, also IP ist so zusammengefasst, das ist irgendwie aufstrittig, dann welche Schichten jetzt?
Also in der Stelle sollte man vielleicht noch das ARP-Protokoll erwähnen, dass da ja mehr oder weniger dazwischenkommt, und das dazu dient, auf einem Ethernet festzustellen, welche IP-Adresse, welche Ethernet-Adresse zugeordnet ist. Man kann ARP auch benutzen, um verschiedene Spielchen zu machen, wenn man auf demselben lokalen Netz ist, wie ein anderer Rechner. Man kann seine IP-Adresse übernehmen, man kann Verbindungen, die für ihn sind, redirecten, man kann dafür sorgen, dass er nicht mehr rausgerootet wird, usw.
Genau, und bei diesen Ethernet-Adressen, die nennen sich auch MAC-Adressen oder MAC-Adressen, oder MAC, Media Assess Control, heißt es wohl, und da gibt es dann auch verschiedene Adressen. Also jede Ethernet-Karte hat eine Seriennummer, die wird also vom Hersteller vergeben, da gibt es also jeder Hersteller hat einen bestimmten Code, einen bestimmten Bereich von Zahlen, den er vergeben kann.
Also es gibt doch Hersteller aus Taiwan, die einfach irgendwelche Zahlen nehmen, das gibt es auch.
Ja, aber es sollte halt so sein, dass eigentlich jede Ethernet-Karte eine eigene Seriennummer hat, sozusagen eine eigene Nummer, die dann auch im Netz verwendet wird und damit auch einländig identifizierbar ist.
Also man kann inzwischen schon selbst umschreiben.
Kannst du inzwischen bei Ancard machen.
Genau.
Das ist auch wichtig übrigens, also das ist nicht nur um Hacker eine Freude zu machen, sondern das braucht man für High Availability, also wenn man zwei Rechner nebeneinander stellt und wenn der Hauptserver auswählt, soll der andere halt übernehmen, dann braucht man das.
Wird nicht bei IPv6 irgendwie die MAC-Adresse dann in die IP-Adresse mit eingebunden?
Ja, aber so weit sind vielleicht nicht.
Also IPv6 für alle, die das mal nicht so kennen, also im Moment ist IPv4 aktuell, also IP-Version 4. Das ist also das, was wir so verwenden, alle mit den IP-Adressen. Das sind also meinetwegen 192, 168, 12.1 oder sowas. Das sind also dann die IPv4-Adressen und vielleicht habt ihr auch schon mal gehört, dass die in dieser Zeit ein bisschen knapp werden, weil die nämlich irgendwie sehr verschwenderisch vergeben worden sind. Na ja, eigentlich, man muss sie ja auch vergeben, dafür sind sie ja auch da. Aber die werden jetzt einfach knapp, weil es hat eigentlich auch kaum jemand damit gerechnet, dass das Internet so schnell wächst. Und jetzt hat man sich unter anderem deswegen, aber auch wegen ein paar Sicherheitsmängeln, was Felix ja schon erwähnt hat, hat man sich jetzt auf einen IPv6-Protokoll verständigt.
Also eigentlich sind sie nicht knapp, sondern sie sind halt bloß scheiße verteilt. Also man versucht halt irgendwie... Entschuldigung, ich sag nicht mehr scheiße. Ich hab noch gar nichts gesagt.
Das ist also einfach bedingt durch das Routing, das heißt also wie Nachrichten verteilt werden im Internet, wie Rechner an andere Netze angeschlossen werden. Es ist einfach so bedingt, dass diese IP-Adressen sehr verschwenderisch vergeben werden müssen, einfach.
Na eigentlich nicht, also man könnte da auch schon geschickt machen. Aber das lief halt so, dass am Anfang, als das Netz noch klein war, da war halt MIT am Netz und da war Berkeley am Netz und da haben die sich halt jeweils 16 Millionen IP-Adressen gekrallt. Und deswegen sind die jetzt eben weg und davon werden vielleicht ein paar tausend benutzt intern. Und der Rest liegt halt braach.
Also man könnte mit IPv4 wahrscheinlich noch eine Menge machen.
Könnte man auch mindestens ein Jahrhundert überleben, denn das sind 4 Billionen, 4 Milliarden IP-Adressen, das sollte eigentlich schon mal reichen.
Nicht wenn jede Kaffeemaschine ihre eigene IP-Adresse hat.
Na das wollen wir ja auch nicht, oder?
So, jetzt hab ich diese ganzen Protokolle jetzt gerade serviert bekommen und hab jetzt gerade überlegt, was macht ihr damit? Also gibt es da irgendwelche Angriffsmöglichkeiten oder was können da Menschen machen? Böse Menschen vielleicht auch. Ihr seid ja die Guten und könnt das rausfinden, was man damit machen kann. Gibt es da so Angriffsmöglichkeiten? Ich sag zwischendurch auch nochmal die Telefonnummer 031 70 97 110. Wenn ihr irgendein Protokollproblem habt, könnt ihr gerade jetzt besonders gut anrufen und das...
Das hättest du jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen sollen. Ich hab neulich meine Oma angerufen und die haben gesagt...
Was?
Na, das ist auch ein Protokoll.
Nee, also wenn man ernsthafte Protokollprobleme hat oder ähnliches. Aber gibt es da jetzt für euch irgendwelche Möglichkeiten? Gibt es da Sicherheitslöcken oder ähnliches? Bei solchen Geschichten, oder muss man da auf irgendwas achten? Bei so Protokollen?
Na ja, teilweise sind die Sicherheitslöcken tatsächlich Protokollinherent, hatten wir ja schon erwähnt. So Geschichten wie bei ICMP, wenn man halt an das Netz ran kann, dann kann man ICMP-Pakete erzeugen. Es gibt da gar keine Absicherung. Und auch bei ARP gibt es ähnliche Probleme. Was bei TCP tatsächlich auch aus der Entfernung nutzbar ist, eine Protokollschwäche, sind sogenannte Sequence Number Guessing Attacks. Also man kann ja die Absender-IP-Adresse fälschen. Also bei UDP ist es gar kein Problem. Bei UDP gibt es kein State. Das heißt, man kann ein UDP-Paket hinschicken, kann irgendeine IP-Adresse reinschreiben. Das kommt an, wird verarbeitet und funktioniert. Bei TCP ist es so, dass er immer auf eine Verbindung hin auch wieder Pakete zurückschicken muss, damit die Daten hin und her transportiert werden. Wenn man eine falsche IP-Adresse eingibt, beim Hinschicken, dann kommen die Pakete nicht zurück. Und man kann keine Verbindung aufbauen. An der Stelle muss man die sogenannte Sequence Number im TCP-Header raten. Wenn man die richtig rät, kann man Pakete erzeugen, obwohl man die Antwort nicht gesehen hat. Das heißt, man schickt was hin, bekommt eine Antwort nicht zurück, weil sie an den falschen Port geht, weiß aber, wie sie aussieht und kann dann wieder das richtige Paket hin erzeugen. Und die Daten kommen an. Das heißt, es gibt Probleme, die stecken einmal im Protokoll selber drin. Oder bei diesem Beispiel der Sequence Numbers sind in der Implementation drin. Also, in dem Fall, das Raten der Sequence Numbers funktioniert halt nur bei Systemen, die dagegen nicht sicher sind. Gute Systeme erzeugen die Sequence Numbers zufällig.
Gibt's da irgendwie so ein klassisches Beispiel? Also wenn ich da so ganz als normaler Internet oder sonst wie User irgendwie rumrechne, benutze ich das irgendwann? Und ich weiß es gar nicht, und da kann irgendwer ran?
Naja, also TCP benutzt du grundsätzlich immer. Und ob diese Schwäche in deinem Rechner drin ist oder nicht, kannst du natürlich erstmal als normaler User nicht feststellen. Es sei denn du verwendest dieselben Tools, die auch zum Hacken der Rechner verwendet werden. Also ein Tool, das du zum Beispiel feststellen kannst, ist Nmap, ein Portscanner, der neben der Portscanning-Fähigkeit noch andere Fähigkeiten hat. So kann er zum Beispiel das Betriebssystem erkennen, das der andere User verwendet. Und das macht so Sachen wie die Sequence-Number, sich angucken, ob man die raten kann oder nicht. Und man kann damit auch durch Firewalls durchscannen usw. Das ist ein Tool, das sehr beliebt ist für erste Phase eines Angriffs. Aber ganz genauso beliebt ist es bei den Leuten, die ihren Rechner absichern müssen, um zu sehen, wo es da Probleme gibt.
Da hab ich doch jemanden in der Leitung, der euch interessieren dürfte. Jan17 aus Berlin zum Thema Firewalls.
Ja, tschüss, guten Abend. Ich hab bei mir so einen kleinen Physik-Nachteil, den ich irgendwo ganz billig abgestaut habe, hingestellt als Router. Und hab da auch ganz billig, ohne viel Ahnung zu haben, einfach so ein Suze-Masquerading drauf gemacht.
Ja, dachte ich mir.
Und hab so ein, weiß nicht, drei, vier Rechernetzler dahinter. Und Masquerading ist ja praktisch, dass sich die internen IPs dahinter masqueradieren und nach draußen gehen über die eine IP vom Einwahl-Account, stimmt's?
Also das heißt, die internen Adressen, da ist ja wahrscheinlich diese 192er-Adresse, das muss man vielleicht mal für die anderen Hörer noch sagen. Es gibt also einen Bereich bei diesen IP-Adressen, der nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt ist, sozusagen. Das ist also der beliebteste wahrscheinlich, diese 192.168 und alles, was dahinter hängt. Das sind also Adressen, die nicht im öffentlichen Netzen verwendet werden dürfen. Und die sind gerade für so privaten Sachen geeignet. Und dadurch, dass man die einfach auch nicht erreichen kann, die werden von allen Routern praktisch ignoriert, auch überall im Internet, ist es nicht möglich, deine Rechner damit von draußen zu erreichen, selbst wenn man das irgendwie wollte.
Naja, naja, genau das ist die Frage. Naja, naja, wenn ich jetzt einfach nur einen Routing setzen würde und das Masquerading weglassen würde, dann kommst du raus, aber die Antwort kommt nicht zurück.
Das heißt, für dich sieht das so aus, als wenn das Internet gerade ausgefallen ist.
Achso, die Pakete kommen raus, die Pakete kommen nicht rein.
Na, der Rechner, mit dem du zu reden versuchst, weiß nicht, wer dir antworten soll und schmeißt das Paket dann auf den Weg weg.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Firewall drin hatte, dann würde der, also angenommen, also statt auf meinen Server, auf meinen tollen 486er, könnte ich ja auch statt Scraping einfach jetzt eine Firewall drauf mal konfigurieren.
Das ist nicht unbedingt vergleichbar. Also eine Firewall soll ja in erster Linie auch Sachen von außen ablocken. Das heißt zum Beispiel auch um deinen 486er zu schützen.
Ich bin hier, wir sollten da vielleicht auch die Begrifflichkeit ein bisschen klarer definieren. Ich bin ja schon im Chat kontrolliert worden. Also eine Firewall ist grundsätzlich mehr als das, was ich vorhin meinte, als ich Firewall sagte, nämlich was ich da meinte, war ein Packetfilter. Ein Packetfilter ist ein Rechner, der zwischen zwei Netzwerken sitzt und nur bestimmte Pakete durchlässt. Und das wird bei normalen Packetfiltern, die unter anderem auch bei Linux mitgeliefert sind im Kernel, anhand von den IP-Nummern und dem so gewissen Headerflex und dem Port entschieden. Nicht aber an dem Inhalt. Das heißt ein Firewall oder ein Packetfilter wird erstmal nicht wegfiltern, dass da jemand versucht halt über HTTP, also mit deinem Web-Server, irgendeinen speziellen Bug auszunutzen, sondern ein Packetfilter kann nur verhindern, dass jemand FTP-Bugs ausnutzt bei dir, indem FTP halt weggefiltert wird.
Die Portadresse einfach.
Und eine Firewall ist eigentlich mehr als ein Packetfilter. Eine Firewall ist eine Konfiguration. Und man sagt da gewöhnlich aus zwei Packetfiltern und einem Netz dazwischen. Da gibt es tolle Bücher drüber. Ich weiß nicht, können wir jetzt ein spezielles pluggen? Also es gibt eins von O'Reilly, das ist eigentlich ganz brauchbar. Ja, wer sich über Firewalls interessiert, da gibt es glaube ich auch eine Fake zu. Aber ich würde das O'Reilly Buch empfehlen. Einfach zum Buch halten gehen, antunten.
Kurze andere Verständnis für euch. Ich habe ja, also nicht alle, sondern ein Rechner. Schande, Schande, Schande, ist ein Windows drauf und ein ICQ. Und da gehen ja klar auch Sachen hin und zurück. Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf die IP von meinem SUSE Rechner, einen FTP mache, dann sehe ich natürlich den FTP Server von dem 486er dran. Anders als die anderen Pakete gehen durch auf den anderen Rechner, wo das ICQ läuft. Wie genau funktioniert das?
Na ja, dein Maskeriding Server, also dein Router oder wie auch immer, der nimmt sozusagen die Pakete von deinem internen Netz an. Merkt sich das von wem die kann, von welchem Rechner, schickt die dann mit einer anderen IP-Adresse weiter. Und wenn es dazu eine Antwort gibt von der Gegenseite, zum Beispiel von dem ICQ-Server oder sowas, dann guckt er nach, aha, wer hat es ursprünglich losgeschickt und der kriegt es dann auch zurück. So funktioniert Maskeriding.
Das heißt, ein Bau oder das anderes kommt zum Beispiel nicht durch, weil es da keine Antwort ist, sondern weil es eine...
Richtig, die können einfach diese Rechner gar nicht adressieren. Also nur dein Linux-Rechner ist erst mal primäres Angriffsziel, sozusagen von außen, weil du hast ja von deinem Provider wahrscheinlich auch nur eine IP-Adresse, wenn du dich da einwirfst, dann ist auch mit den anderen da gar nichts zu wollen. Irgendwie gibt es keine Möglichkeit praktisch dahin zu kommen. Hast du denn schon mal deinen Rechner mal getestet auf Sicherheit? Vielleicht schon mal so ein Portscannen oder sowas gemacht? Welche Sachen da offen sind?
Welchen denn du denn?
Den, den, den... Jaja klar, das ist ja der der wichtige sozusagen, der vorher wollte.
Ich hab's gemacht, aber...
Also der Punkt ist, dass du alles wegschmeißt und dann die Sachen, die echt fehlen, wieder reinbaust, nachdem du dich ungefähr einen Monat lang davon überzeugt hast, dass es auch echt sicher ist. Also so macht man Sicherheit.
Genau, also so werden halt auch richtige Firewalls konfiguriert. Das heißt, man überlegt sich erstmal, wir sperren erstmal alles so, nichts ist erlaubt so. Und dann kommen halt die Leute irgendwie an genervt. Ich will aber webklicken. Na gut, krieg Sport 80. Ja, ich will aber irgendwie meine Mail über Popzi. Na gut, krieg Sport 110. So funktioniert es, so muss man sich das vorstellen. Erstmal beantwortet?
So, wollt ihr jetzt gleich nochmal eine Win 98 Frage beantworten? Oder habt ihr ja keinen Bock drauf?
Ja, ja.
Na gut, dann sagen wir Linus hier lange beantwortet.
Genau.
Hier tut Monika glaube ich einen echten Gefallen, wenn sie jetzt auch dran ist. Hallo, Monika.
Ja, hallo. Ich wollte mal eine Frage stellen. Mein Kumpel hat jetzt Win 98. Und der stürzt andauernd ab. Ist überhaupt Win 98 schon mal getestet worden?
Ruf doch mal an.
Also wir testen ganz viel mit Win 98. Also Katastrophentests, Ausfallsicherungstests. Nein, also Win 98 ist schon getestet worden, aber es ist halt auch bei den Tests als instabil.
Aber trotzdem ausgeliefert worden.
Ich wollte mir nämlich jetzt auch einen Computer holen und da wollte ich mich einfach mal akkuunieren bei euch, ob das jetzt auch schon getestet wurde.
Ja, es wurde schon getestet, aber da merkste nicht viel von.
Aber, Monika, du brauchst den Rechner eher für ganz normale Geschichten.
Nein, ich brauch das Internet, weil ich hab jetzt einen Freund und der wohnt ein bisschen weiter weg, sodass wir uns auch schreiben können.
Also das ist nicht so ganz ohne so einen Windows-Rechner einfach so ans Internet anzuschließen. Du kannst natürlich mal beim Provider fragen. Ich weiß nicht, hast du schon einen Provider-Zugang zum Internet?
T-Online hab ich.
T-Online, aber bei denen wird das wohl noch nicht gehen. Also manche Provider bieten tatsächlich auch schon Firewalls an, hab ich gehört, für Kunden, die das also schützen.
Ja, das kostet natürlich extra.
Ja, ich hab gehört, vielleicht noch zu dem, es gibt eine Geschichte in, oh Gott, wo war das, Singapur? Das kam bei uns über die Mailing-Liste. Da ist sogar schon ein Provider, die Kundenrechner testen auf bestimmte Sachen.
Ja, aber ohne zu fragen vorher, das war irgendwie, ich glaube nicht, dass die da, also das war eine ganz lustige Story, weil der hat nämlich, ich glaube, das war sogar die Telekom in Singapur, also irgendwie der größte Anbieter von Internet. Der hat einfach alle seine Kundenrechner gepaart, kennt so, und die fanden das natürlich gar nicht witzig. Und der meinte dann, ja, aber wir wollten euch doch nur helfen. Also ich würde mal glauben, dass irgendein Administrator da mit N-Map rumgespielt hat und dann haben sie im Nachhinein versucht, den dort in Zweck zu halten. Das haben wir doch nur gemacht, weil wir eure Freunde sind.
Ja, also denkt ihr auf jeden Fall irgendwie was aus, oder vielleicht schaut es auch mal im Internet. Es gibt glaube ich so Programme, die Windows da, also in Anführungszeichen, sicherer machen oder sicherer machen, dass einfach die Standardsachen nicht gehen. Dann gibt es unter Windows zum Beispiel auch so eine Freigabe. Also ich weiß nicht, wie gut ich mich mit deinem Computer auskenne, mit Windows, aber da gibt es Freigaben. Also gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass andere Leute auf deine Laufwerke zu greifen können, auf deine Festplatten. Das ist so geplant. Also wenn du auf deinem Büro bist und der Chef soll mit Sekretärin und die wollen irgendwelche Sachen austauschen, dann kann man sich gegenseitig die Festplatten freigeben. Und das ist eine beliebte Angriffsmöglichkeit bei Windows, weil manchmal sind die einfach für alle freigegeben. Das ist dann der Port 139 glaube ich. Und das kann man auch mal ganz gerne bei Windows rechnen, guck ob da irgendwas offen ist und dann kann man einfach mal lustig die ganze Festplatte auslesen oder auch alles löschen oder wie man gerade Lust hat.
Dann sind der ganzen Liebesbrief weg, Monika. Aber jetzt nochmal, also ich glaube dir geht es ja weniger um die Sicherheit. Also ihr könnt ja nicht empfehlen jetzt Windows 98 zu holen.
Nein, eigentlich kann ich mir nicht empfehlen Windows zu installieren, aber was will zu machen?
Hast du schon mal danach gedacht vielleicht auch einen Mac zu holen? Also auch wenn ein Mac vielleicht nicht unbedingt sicherer ist, aber es ist einfach eine Alternative. Windows NT.
Ja, ist auch von Microsoft, also ist auch schlecht.
Es ist schon, kann man sagen, es ist ein bisschen sicherer, also es wird ja auch ganz gern als Server. Aber ich schätze mal für deine Bedürfnisse wäre Windows 98 dann schon die bessere Wahl als Windows NT, auch weil es teurer ist und auch viel mächtiger. Mach das mal aber sie zu, dass du das Ding irgendwie sicher kriegst und vor allem vielleicht dass du auch ganz wichtige Sachen, persönliche Sachen wie irgendwelche, wenn du online Banking trotz allen Warnungen machst, deine Zugriffsachen natürlich auch nicht drauf lässt und auch irgendwelche Passwörter nicht auf der Festplatte lässt. Also einfach auf die Kette speichern, die Kette rausnehmen oder auf Zettel schreiben. Dann merken am besten noch.
Also kann ich mir das gleich für morgen merken, weil morgen kommt dann nämlich...
Genau, kannste ihm so sagen. Und außerdem für das Windows 98 Problem, das er hat, dass das Ding immer absturz braucht, glaube ich, einfach nur mal irgendeinen anderen Service Menschen da zu fragen. Da scheint er irgendwas anderes falsch zu machen, was wir jetzt nicht rauskriegen.
Immer den Händen abnerven, weil die haben von euch Geld kassiert, die haben gefälligst auch Support zu leisten.
Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Können wir vielleicht mal einen Zwischenstand von unserem...
Ja genau, wir haben mal einen Report hier von unserem Opfer.
Also wir haben jetzt vor einer guten Stunde ein kleines Spielchen angesettelt, was euch dazu aufgerufen hatte, doch einfach mal einen Rechner in Hamburg euch vorzunehmen und den zu hacken. Ist da jetzt schon irgendwas zu sehen?
Felix?
Ja, da sieht man gelegentlich Leute, die versuchen diverse Exploits auszuprobieren. So CGI Exploits sehe ich da. Test CGI und CGI Bin slash SH.
Ja, ihr lacht jetzt so. Sagt mir, ob das irgendwie wahnsinnig toll ist. Ist da jemand darunter, der fähig ist oder sind das alles in euren Augen?
Nein, das können wir jetzt natürlich noch nicht beobachten, weil das könnte ja auch sein, dass sie nur dumm tun, damit wir sie unterschätzen. Das ist ja auch eine gute Strategie eigentlich.
Also es gibt weiterhin die Möglichkeit, diesen Rechner zu hacken. Eine Sache vielleicht noch mal die Adresse, Frank.
Das ist playground.linuxsecurity.de oder in numerischer IP-Adresse ist das dann die 195.222.228.123.
Pfeffer, kannst du dich auch noch mal in den WeChat reinzerren, unter www.fritz.de über den Chat den WeChat aufrufen.
Ja, wir haben ja schon ein paar Anfragen gekriegt, ob wir nicht zum Camp was sagen.
Ah, das Camp, um Gottes Willen, ja, natürlich.
Genau, also wir machen in diesem Jahr ein Camp. Das wird veranstaltet, das ist in der Nähe von Berlin. Das heißt, genau der Radius, der Zuhörer hier.
Also ungefähr 20 Kilometer.
Ihr macht ein reales Camp?
Nicht virtuell oder so?
Nee, nee, da kannst du endlich die Leute mal kennen, die immer deinen Rechner zum Absturz bringen.
Ihr traut euch und das Volk ohne Anschluss?
Nein, nein, nein.
Selbstverständlich wird es da Internet geben. Stell dir das so vor, eine Wiese, ein See, Wald, Strom, Internet und Zelte.
Das heißt, ihr seht weder Wald noch See, ihr geht auch nie baden, sondern nicht gehen wir baden.
Unsere Rechner gehen baden, die schmeißen wir alle rein.
Es gibt auch schon wasserdichte Tastaturen, die kommen mit ins Wasser nehmen und dann von da aus...
Genau, es gibt ja sonst immer jedes Jahr im Abend zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr den Chaos Communication Congress. Wir haben uns gedacht, mal im Winter zu treffen ist blöd, also das machen wir dieses Jahr natürlich auch wieder. Aber wir wollen einfach mal in Urlaub fahren, da ganz entspannt campen.
Stimmt, entspannt.
Ja, ein bisschen hacken, ein bisschen fortbilden, ein bisschen dumm quatschen und einfach mal ein Wochenende genießen.
Also Leute, nutzt die Kunst der Stunde und hackt mal draußen an der frischen Luft, das ist ganz nett.
Vor allem eine Sache, die wir planen, ist da ein Deathmatch zu machen. Das können wir vielleicht kurz erläutern, was das ist. Das haben wir nämlich schon mal gemacht in Berlin. Und zwar die Idee ist, dass man da Rechner in ein kleines Netz tut, die einfach bestückt sind mit einer Standarddienungsinstallation. Und Freiwillige können sich da da ransetzen und versuchen sich gegenseitig zu hacken. Und es gibt dann Punkte pro Minute, wenn gewisse Dienste laufen, also wenn Mail erreichbar ist. Und wenn man per Pop dann Mail lesen kann und wenn ein Webserver läuft, dann kriegt man Punkte dafür. Das heißt, das Ziel ist, auf seinem eigenen Rechner die ganzen Dienste laufen zu lassen. Und die anderen Rechner möglichst unerreichbar zu halten oder am besten noch da einzubrechen, Daten zu verfälschen. Also das läuft dann einige Stunden und es gibt einen Kommentator, das war beim letzten Mal ich, vielleicht kann ich nächstes Mal mithacken und jemand anders kommentieren. Mal schauen, jedenfalls, das war also echt lustig, hat sich bewährt und das wird sich ja eine nette Sache beim Camp.
Aber das ganze Camp wird ja im Allgemeinen ein einziges Desmatch sein.
Ja, dann mal wir hoffen, dass die Menschen in den Grünen nicht so oft dabei sind und vorbeikommen.
Zu denen sagen wir nachher noch was.
Gut, wir machen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen Schnaufpause. Bis zum Kurzinfo. Ihr könnt euch schon wieder neue Fragen überlegen, wie ihr diese Menschen, die ihr so viel wissen, so richtig quält mit fiesen Fragen.
Wir sind ja so toll.
Ach ja, von ray.net liegt übrigens vorne, mit mittlerweile über 130 versuchten Exploiten. Unter anderem einen NFSD-Exploit habe ich hier gesehen. Der von ADM?
Glückwunsch, Ray.
Ja, weiter so, weiter so.
Der Chaos Computer Club im Studio bei Fritz. Wir blenden uns hier langsam aus und machen gleich weiter.
Macht aus.
Macht aus. Macht aus.
Manos. Manus.
Das ist das angenehme an diesem Abend im Chaos Computer Club. Ich muss den Sound nicht selbst machen, sondern hier an unseren Turntables steht jemand, nämlich Maton, und legt eine Platte nach der anderen auf und macht den Sound zum Computer Chaos. So, mittlerweile ist Svenja wieder im Studio. Wir haben 23.31 Uhr.
Europa Pokal. Manchester United hat am Abend die Champions League 1999 in Barcelona gewonnen. Die britische Fußballmannschaft besiegte den deutschen Meister Bayern München mit 2 zu 1 und in Bayern wurde frustriert gegen die Couchtische getreten. Die beiden Tore für Manchester fielen erst in der Nachspielzeit. Kriegsverbrecher. Jugoslawiens Präsident Milošević soll nach den US Informationen noch in dieser Woche vom UNO Kriegsverbrecher Tribunal in Den Haag angeklagt werden. Danach sollen ihm voraussichtlich Kriegsverbrechen im Kosovo zur Last gelegt werden. Der Haftbewel ist bereits unterschrieben, hieß es weiter. Strategie. Die NATO hat ihre Luftangriffe auf Ziele in Jugoslawien und im Kosovo auch heute fortgesetzt. Gleichzeitig ging die Vertreibung der albanischen Bevölkerung durch serbische Einheiten weiter. Absicht. Bundesgesundheitsministerin Fischer hat ihren Gesetzentwurf für die Gesundheitsreform vorgestellt. Kern ist ein festes Ausgabenbudget von 250 Milliarden Mark jährlich. Das Gesetz wird von der Ärzteschaft und der Pharmaindustrie kritisiert. Einschränkungen. Die Ansiedlung weiterer Fabrik-Verkaufszentren am Stadtrand von Berlin soll in Zukunft nach Möglichkeit verhindert werden. Darauf haben sich heute die Länder Berlin und Brandenburg in der gemeinsamen Landesplanungskonferenz verständigt. Wetter. Nachts gering bewirkt oder klar um 6 Grad tagsmeist sonnig, Höchstwerte bis 27 Grad. B115 Cottbus-Fetschau zwischen Cottbus und Kolkwitz. Sperrung der B115 gegen Bauarbeiten bis ungefähr 2 Uhr. Umfahrt die Baustelle über die A15 oder nutzt die L50 über Hähnchen.
Svenja Baumgartner mit dem Fritz Info. Die Zeit 23.33.3 nach halb 12. Hallo, hallo.
Sensible Myter hören jetzt lieber weg. Jetzt kommt nämlich was super ekligen. Eigenwerbung, ich könnte gleich brechen, ich mache jetzt wieder Eigenwerbung und dann habe ich mir überlegt, wie macht man es am besten? Sei bescheiden, insofern fällt mir nur gerade ein, am 31. Mai ist Montag um 21 Uhr in der Volksbühne wieder ein Video-Schnipsel. Vorausrecht völlig unwichtig. The rest of the year, also alle Tittes zu sehen, was bisher noch nicht zu sehen war. Nehmt es nicht so ernst, 31. Wir sehen uns, oder?
Die Krempe wird hier durch die Gegend geschossen. Kekse auf unsere Konsolen gekleckert.
Wie eure Konsolen?
Vier Menschen sind hier, die Bildschirme vor den Augen haben. Es kann sich nur um einen Blue Moon mit dem Chaos Computer Club handeln. Ich bin Mec Warbeck und die vier Herren hier im Studio heißen Andreas, Felix, Jan und Frank. Und der, der an den Turn Tables heißt Marthorn. So, wo waren wir stehen geblieben eben? Wir waren stehen geblieben bei Protokollen und ihren Angriffsmöglichkeiten. Jetzt sage ich doch noch mal schnell unsere Angriffsmöglichkeiten durch. Man kann uns angreifen unter 0331 70 97 1 99. Das wäre dann per Telefon. Oder man kann Felix im VJET unter www.fritz.de slash VJET auch angreifen und ihn ganz böse beschimpfen.
Immer rauf, immer rauf.
Aber er schimpft dann gnadenlos zurück.
Und ihr sollt natürlich auch angreifen in den Rechner Playground.linuxsecurity.de bzw. 195.222.228.123.
Was gibt es eigentlich für den, der den schafft?
Den, der Wien gelohnt.
Ach so, das alles?
Wie das ist alles?
Friseure sind echt mehr geworden. So Ferraris.
Weil so viel gebraucht war, wie er tragen kann.
Das ist natürlich das Lockpile auf dem Tab-Surfer.
Ich sag für alle Leute, die jetzt sich später einschalten, wenn es so ganz profane sind, wie schalte ich einen Rechner an, bitte nicht anrufen, weil das können wir hier nicht klären.
Wie sagen wir, wenn man ihn ausschaltet?
Die zweite Geschichte ist, wenn ihr jetzt denkt, ihr habt schon eineinhalb Stunden verpasst und möglicherweise auch ganz wichtige Hinweise über Protokolle und so eben verpasst, das Ganze wird es morgen als Real Audio und MP3 bei Fritz im Netz geben. Müsst ihr einfach nur drausfischen. Und ihr könnt das Ganze auch als, wie sagt man das? Live Audio im Netz erleben, wenn ihr irgendwo anders hinfahren wollt oder so. So, ich bin soweit durch. Wenn ihr jetzt mit den Tools, mit den richtig schicken kleinen Werkzeugen anfangen wolltet.
Wir wollten ein bisschen was erklären, was wir denn so, was unsere persönlichen Vorlieben sind sozusagen bei den Tools, was wir dann auch so verwenden. Diese ganzen Sachen gibt es meist unter Unix, unter Linux speziell auch oder unter BSD, was irgendwie euer Lieblingsbetriebssystem ist. Die meisten Sachen gibt es oder viele Sachen gibt es nicht für Windows, weil es sich einfach als Betriebssystem für Hacker sozusagen nicht bewertet. Man kann mit Linux viel schönere Sachen oder mit Unix viel schönere Sachen machen. Man kann da viel Betriebssystem näher programmieren. Man kann auf dem Netzwerk viel mehr herumprobieren und deswegen gibt es die meisten Sachen einfach am besten unter Linux. Ja, nMap hat man schon ein bisschen angedeutet. Vielleicht kann Andreas oder Felix nochmal kurz erzählen, was nMap genau alles kann oder was nMap so an Feinheiten hat, was ein einfacher Portscanner wie, ja was gibt es da? Portscan. Genau, wo man einfach die Ports durchprobiert. Was sind da die Vorteile noch von nMap?
Ja, der klassische Scan mit Strobe ist einfach so, dass man probiert eine Verbindung aufzumachen zu einem Port und wenn es erfolgreich war, weiß man, der Port ist offen. Das Problem ist dabei, dass man das natürlich auch auf der anderen Seite in den Logfiles sieht, weil dann meistens so was drin steht wie Remote Host Closed Connection zusammen mit der IP-Adresse und man deutliche Spuren hinterlässt. Und nMap hat jetzt mehrere Möglichkeiten für so eine Stealth-Scan eingebaut, wo hinterher keine Einträge in den Logfiles geschrieben werden. Bei den meisten Systemen, bei einem System gibt es natürlich spezielle Filter, die auch das abfangen. Und zwar funktioniert das so, dass man nicht sagt, ich möchte eine Verbindung öffnen in seinem TCP-Paket, sondern man sagt, ich möchte die Verbindung schließen. Und dann sagt die andere Seite entweder, wenn die Verbindung, wenn der Port nicht offen ist, sagt er, wovon redest du eigentlich? Und wenn der Port offen ist, sagt er, deine Sequence-Number kenne ich aber nicht. Und so kann man unterscheiden, ob der Port da ist oder nicht. Und entweder partierst du nachher Scans mit diesen Reset-Paketen, mit Fins, mit allen Flex eingeschaltet, worauf dann alle Systeme sehr merkwürdig reagieren und so weiter und so fort. Was es dabei auch gibt, ist ein Fragment-Scan. Das heißt, dass das TCP-Paket in mehrere Teile zerlegt wird. Und Packetfilter können normalerweise nur den ersten Teil eines Paketes analysieren. Und die anderen müssen sie einfach durchlassen, weil da der Header nicht mehr drin ist. Und wenn man auf so eine Firewall trifft, kann man mit dem Fragment-Scan da durchscannen, indem einfach da Fragments geschickt werden. Und das Paket ist zu kurz, der TCP-Hader ist nicht komplett drin. Und dann sagt er, das kann ich aber nicht analysieren, lässt es durch. Und dann kommt es halt trotzdem bei dem Rechner an. Dann gibt es in Nmap Möglichkeiten, ganze Netze auf einmal zu scannen. Das heißt, man kann sagen, scan 10.1.1.0 slash 24. 24 ist dann die Anzahl der Bits in der Netzmaske. Und dann wird das ganze Klassenzenetz gescannt. Man kann Ping-Scans machen, das heißt gucken, welche Hosts sind oben. Und das waren eigentlich glaube ich schon fast alle wichtigen Features.
Ein ganz, ganz wichtiges, ganz interessantes Feature ist was, genau die OS-Detection. Es gab erst ein Programm, es nannte sich KESO. Das war ein einzelnes Programm, ein alleinstehendes Programm. Und zwar stelle ich damit ganz, ganz einfach fest, welches Betriebssystem, was für ein Rechner auf der anderen Seite läuft. Ob ich da jetzt irgendwie ein Windows-Gerät habe, oder eine Linux-Version so und so, oder vielleicht auch einen Cisco-Router oder so. Und das kann mir auch schon mal ganz gut weiterhelfen. Es gibt ganz gute Ansatzpunkte, wo ich dann weiter machen kann, wo ich überhaupt probieren kann, oder wo ich es gleich lassen kann, weil es fällt irgendwo blöd auf im Lock-File von einer Firewall oder sonst wo. Und das ist schon mal auch noch ein ganz wichtiges Feature. Ich persönlich finde NetCut ist ein ganz praktisches Programm. Es ist also ein kleines Tool, ein kleines Programm, womit man einfach was aufs Netzwerk schreiben kann. Das heißt, ich habe einfach eine Datei, zum Beispiel eine übliche Anwälteprozidur für ein Mail-Protokoll oder sowas, und kann es dann ganz einfach irgendeinem Rechner sagen. Ich gebe da dann die Zieladresse an, die Ziel-IP-Nummer und den Port, wo es hin soll, also zum Beispiel für Mail-Port 25, und kann dann einfach eine Textdatei, die ich vorher vorbereitet habe, dann da hinschicken.
Bringt mir genau was dann?
Das erleichtert mir einfach die Arbeit. Das ist so ein Programm wie irgendwie, ja wie soll man das vergleichen, wie vielleicht ein Stempel oder so. Ich muss ja nicht alles neu schreiben, irgendwie muss ich halt nicht das Datum, nicht das Formular nur eintragen, sondern ich drücke da irgendwie ein Datum-Stempel drauf. So eine Vereinfachung ist das ungefähr. Und nebenbei hat es auch noch die Funktion, auf Ports zu hören. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt also sozusagen als Server, als Dämon irgendwie einsetzen. Das heißt, ich sag, du hörst jetzt einfach mal auf Port 387 auf dem Rechner und ich kann dann zum Beispiel, wenn ich eine Firewall testen möchte, ob die funktioniert, kann ich von außen dann irgendwie versuchen, diesen Port anzugreifen und der reagiert dann irgendwie darauf, so wie ich das will.
Man sollte vielleicht sagen, NetCut braucht man auch, wenn man zum Beispiel mit einem SAP-System reden will, ohne ein SAP GUI installiert zu haben. Oder wenn man einen Dienst benutzen möchte, zu dem man keinen client installiert hat.
Was ist denn dein Lieblingstool, Felix?
Ich benutze NetCut schon ganz häufig, muss ich sagen. Nmap ist ein Klassiker, klar. Jeder hat da seine Lieblingstools. Was ich ganz gerne benutze ist Hunch. Das ist ein Tool, mit dem man nette Abspiele reinmachen kann. Gut, ich sage jetzt hier nur den Toolnamen. Das ist Absicht, nicht dass jemand nach einer URL fragt. Denn das ist der Eigenungstest. Wer das nicht selber findet, der hat es auch nicht verdient.
Jan, hast du auch ein extra Lieblingswerkzeug?
Also ich habe bis jetzt irgendwie nur die Portscanner. Und wie jetzt mehr betrachtet, also mein Lieblingswerkzeug ist jetzt im Bereich der Sniffer. Das heißt jetzt Sniffit. Und da gibt es so eine nette Option, die ist Interactive Mode. Also da sieht man direkt die ganzen Pakete, die jetzt gerade über die Netzmaske, über die Ethernet laufen. Und wenn man ein schönes Paket findet, was man sich gerne genau anguckt, dann drückt man einfach Enter und sieht genau, was drüber läuft. Zum Beispiel auch Passwörter, alles Mögliche schöne.
Genau, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel im Netzwerk sitze und mein verhasster Kollege im Nachbarbüro irgendwie hat sich jetzt gerade in einen Urge-Chat eingeklinkt, dann kann ich beim Portscan, quatsch, mit beim Sniffer-Tour sitzen und sehe, aha, mein Nachbar baut jetzt gerade eine Verbindung auf zum Schätzer. Aber na, da drücke ich mal Enter und klick, habe ich schon den ganzen Kram vor mir auf dem Bildschirm, was er da tippt, aber das ist halt illegal. Oder ja, das macht man nicht.
Böse, dreckige Seiten an die URL kann man dann auch mitkriegen.
Also das heißt, dass jeder Kriminalbeamte eigentlich auch gerne so was benutzen könnte, um zum Beispiel, was ich... Sie tun sie... .Kinder-Bonographie auf der Stuhl zu koffieren.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass sowas ja immer nur im lokalen Netzwerk geht, also außerhalb des Firmen-Netzwerks ist das vorbei. Also im Prinzip ist das natürlich auch genau das, was für Abhörmaßnahmen im größeren Stil benutzt wird bei Providern. Das funktioniert eigentlich ähnlich, dass man sich einfach auf die Leitung klemmt und guckt, was da so vor sich geht.
Machen das dann auch die Master, die solche Netze dann beobachten? Nutzen die sowas dann auch, um Leute rauszukicken, die da nicht angenehm sind?
Ne, nicht wirklich. Man nutzt sowas um Fehler. Also ursprünglich kommen diese Sniffer eigentlich aus dem Bereich Netzwerkmanagement oder Netzwerkfehlerbehebung. Das heißt, man guckt, ob da irgendwelche ungültigen Pakete drauf sind. Sowas wird da von den Programmen normalerweise auch angezeigt. Ob irgendwelche fehlerhaften Pakete sind, ob es auf dem Ethernet, oder ob es auf Kollisionen beruht. Also wenn so viele Rechner auf einem Ethernet, auf einem Netzwerkkabel angeschlossen sind, dann gibt es bisher zu viele Kollisionen. Und dann kracht es auch nicht im Netzwerk, und dann kommt da nichts mehr vorwärts. Und sowas kann man damit zum Beispiel auch feststellen und auch sehen, wenn jetzt ein Rechner nur Mist baut, oder nur Mist empfängt, oder immer nur halbe Webseiten empfängt, dann kann man sowas auch damit feststellen.
Also ganz praktisch eigentlich. Ich hab dir gerade noch ein paar Fragen hier von ein paar Hörern.
Und zwar habe ich eine Nachfrage. Und zwar bin ich bei T-Online. Und hab eine Webseite bei Tripod. Und jetzt wollte ich wissen, ob irgendjemand anderes an meine Webseite bei Tripod zurückgreifen kann und die auch verändern kann.
Na ja, das haben wir ja gerade versucht zu erklären. Also wenn jemand Lust hat, jetzt deine Webseite zu verändern, dann benutzt er diese Tools und findet vielleicht einen Weg, um deine Webseite dann zu verändern.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel deine Webseiten von einem Netz aus veränderst und ein Rechner weiter sitzt, jemand hat einen Sniffer zu laufen, dann sieht er dein Passwort und schon kann er deine Webseiten verändern.
Und meine Webseite bei T-Online kannst du aber nicht verändern, irgendwie?
Doch, natürlich.
Das beruht ja alles auf Passwort. Du musst ja sehen, wenn du bei T-Online einwählst, dann wird ein Passwort übers Netz geschickt. Solange du dich von zu Hause mit deinem Modem bei T-Online einwählst, ist es ja ein relativ gestütztes System. Das heißt, es geht nicht einmal durch die ganze Welt. Internet funktioniert einfach so, dass irgendwo in der Welt irgendwelche Rechner verteilt sind. Und wenn man sich mal einen TraceRoute anguckt, das ist ein Programm, womit man Internetverbindungen praktisch zurückverfolgen kann, wie die funktionieren, dann sieht man, dass ich vielleicht meinen Rechner oder einen Rechner in einer Firma, die auch in Berlin sitzt zum Beispiel, anpinge, und dann sehe ich erstmal, dass das Paket nach Frankreich, von da aus nach Amerika rüber, dann kommt es zurück nach England und dann zurück nach Berlin. Und bei T-Online ist es so, dass es von dir zu Hause eigentlich in der Regel erst mal direkt zu T-Online geht. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass da nicht auch jemand mithören kann oder irgendwie das ausnutzen will. Was anderes ist, wenn du zum Beispiel deine Webseiten von der Uni auswarten willst oder von der Firma, dann kann natürlich sehr wohl jemand mit horchen auf der Leitung. Und es kann natürlich auch genauso gut passieren, dass jemand sich einfach bei T-Online einwählt und einfach eine Million Varianten eines Passworts rausprobiert.
Das kann auch passieren, ja. Und weil ich noch wissen wollte, und zwar habe ich mitten im Netz bei JARO noch E-Mail-Adressen. Jetzt wollte ich fragen, wie kann ich die sichern, damit die nicht abgefangen werden und durchgelesen werden, außer mit dem Schlüssel.
PGP benutzen.
Na überhaupt nicht so. Die Free E-Mail Services sind alle Scheiße, sollte man an der Stelle mal sagen. Leute, ihr habt einen Provider, der gibt euch eine E-Mail und die benutzt ihr. Also es gibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Grund, bei yahoo.com oder so, sich eine E-Mail einzurichten. Das bringt nur einem was, nämlich diesen Provider, weil der seine Werbung abdrückt und dafür Kohle kriegt. Und ihr habt davon genau gar nichts. Und die Adresse sieht auch nicht cool aus. Am Anfang war das mal so, dass die Leute dachten, es sieht vielleicht cool aus, wenn irgendwie at yahoo.com da steht. Aber inzwischen ist das alles so wie GMX und so. Das ist alles derartig abgelatscht. Also es gibt Leute, die schon auch gar nicht mehr auf Mails reagieren, die von diesen Free E-Mail Leuten kommen, weil das so auch für Spam gebraucht wird inzwischen. Also geht da weg, das kann man nicht sicher machen. Es gibt einen Anbieter, der gerade ist announced worden, der versucht SSL, also das heißt Web verschlüsselt, Zugriff anzubieten, das wäre dann schon ein bisschen besser. Weil man die Passwörter nicht mitsniffen könnte, wenn die das richtig machen. Aber das weiß man ja auch nicht und das basiert auf irgendeinem Java Applet. Also Finger weg von diesen Free E-Mail Diensten.
Ja und auf jeden Fall solltest du natürlich deine E-Mails auch verschlüsseln. Das verhindert zumindest das jemand anders. Selbst wenn er dein Passwort kennt, dann kann er die E-Mails abrufen und dann kann sie im schlimmsten Fall auch löschen. Aber er kann sie einfach nicht lesen.
Ja bloß wenn sie verschlüsselt sind, haben sie heute auch irgendwie schon rausgekriegt, wie sie lesen können.
Nee, also wenn du PGP benutzt, PGP heißt Pretty Good Privacy, dann kannst du sehr sicher sein, dass deine E-Mails nicht gelesen werden von anderen. Wenn du das richtig benutzt.
Wenn du die International Version benutzt.
Jaja, also das gibt er noch mit einer Exportbestimmung aus Amerika. Aber das ist mittlerweile hier kein Problem.
Eine Sache sollten wir vielleicht noch pluggen. Also wir werden auch ganz häufig gefragt, wie denn das jetzt ist mit der Sicherheit von Online-Banking und so. Und eine Sache, die jeder auf jeden Fall bei sich tun sollte, der Netscape benutzt und Netscape solltet ihr benutzen und nicht den Internet Explorer. Also die Leute, die Netscape benutzen und damit auch tatsächlich verschlüsselt Web machen, sollten Fortify installieren. Das findet man bei www.fortify.net. Fortify, wie das englische Wort, verstärken. Das gibt es auch in Deutschland auf einigen FTP-Servern. Da kann man mal Archiv fragen, zum Beispiel ftp.cert.dfn.de oder einige der lokale Uniservate wahrscheinlich auch. Viele Leute haben das. Was das tut, ist, den Netscape zu patchen, sodass er glaubt, er sei eine US-Version und volle Verschlüsselung benutzt. Das sollte jeder zu Hause installieren. Das ist gut und testen könnt ihr das zum Beispiel dann bei www.ctc.de. Wir haben auch Verschlüsselung und wir finden das gut, wenn die Leute bei uns verschlüsselt connectieren.
Feine Sache dieses. Fabian hat jetzt was kniffliges, eine Netzwerkfrage. Hallo Fabian.
Hi, ich wollte erst mal sagen, ich war auf dem Linux-Test, mitten in Berlin, hab mich prächtig amüsiert und wollte mal fragen, wenn das nächste Mal so stattfindet.
Na, auf dem Camp hoffentlich. Auf dem Camp.
Spätestens auf dem Camp, würde ich sagen. Hast du nicht genau mitgekriegt mit dem Camp eben?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Dann sag doch mal.
Genau, wir machen Anfang August bei Alt Landsberg, das ist hier bei Berlin, ein Sommercamp. Ähnlich zum Chaos Communication Congress, der mal zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr stattfindet.
Da könnt ihr auch alle hinkommen, übrigens.
Genau, da können alle hinkommen. Und da gehen wir raus auf die Wiesel, bauen unsere Zelte auf, packen uns ein bisschen Strom hin, ein bisschen Internet und...
Es gibt genügend Lüfter, da es heute schon offen kein Problem sein sollte.
Genau.
Jetzt meine eigentliche Frage.
IP-Maskerating.
Kann ich das irgendwie umgehen, mit zum Beispiel einem Port-Redirect, weil ich hab ein Problem mit einem Rechner, der hinter einem maskerierten Netz sitzt und auf dem läuft VNC.
Und wollte ich diesen Rechner fernwarten, ist leider ein Windows-Rechner.
Mit einem Linux würde ja mit einem Telnet schon reichen, oder mit einem SSH. Nun ist halt die Frage, ob ich irgendwie an diese maskerierte IP komme, über den Linux-Router.
Du willst von außen dich durchkondinktieren?
Genau.
Koffing geht ja nun nicht, weil halt nur ein Telnet auf dem Linux und auf Windows nicht.
Ja, also was du tun kannst, ist, es gibt ein Modul zum Port-Forwarding bei Linux, oder was du auch machen kannst, ist eben über identity. Wenn du nur weißt, dass du zu genau diesem Rechner konnektieren willst, kannst du das machen. So solltest du im Kernel Special Module Support, heißt das bei IP Masquerading, liest dir die Dokumentation vom Kernel durch. Da brauchst du ein Spezialtool, das steht in der Help von Kernel drin. Und damit kann er dann praktisch... Damit kannst du deinem Masquerading-Host sagen, er soll, wenn von außen jemand auf diesen Port connectet, das weiterleiten intern an diesen einen Rechner.
Benutzt du IP-Chains, also dein neuestes Linux-Kernel? Oder IPv2 oder so? 2036er, ich glaube, das ist noch nicht drin. In dem Neuesten ist es drin. Da gibt es diesen Redirect. Dieses IP-Chains ist deutlich komfortabler und schicker und so was. Versuch mal einen neuen Kernel zu holen, genau. Das ist noch alles gut. Das Ding heißt dann IP-Chains und da gibt es auch ein How-to-File. Und da ist alles wunderbar geschrieben.
Gut, aber ist immer schwierig Windows-Rechner fernzuwarten.
Das ist immer ein bisschen......Namberg-Orifis.
Bitte schön. So, jetzt hatten wir den nächsten hier. Die ISDN-Kanalbündelung ist das Thema von Stefan.
Kleiner Hinweis zwischendurch an die TU in Dresden. Da sitzt jemand, der HTTP nicht richtig spricht. Es heißt GroßHTTP slash 1.0.
Ihr sollt euch nicht immer mit die Lines so lustig machen.
Na, wir haben gesagt, das ist ein Hacker-Contest. Ja, ich weiß.
Nee, aber das ist doch eigentlich schon mal richtig gut.
Sie nutzen sich alle köstlich.
Also gerade mit diesen HTTP-Geschichten, da kommen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen später zu, wie man hackt, ohne entdeckt zu werden. Und da ist mit diesem HTTP-Sprechen, da gibt es Geschichten über Proxys rüber, was manchmal ganz sinnvoll ist. Und da kann man dann auch nochmal lernen, wie man HTTP-Buchstabiert.
Aber es ist immer schön, wenn ihr euch kaputt lacht. Dann weiß ich immer sofort, wer ist sie? Jemand dabei, der könnte ich sein. Hier ist ein anderer Stefan dran, aus Berlin. Bist du noch dran? Hast du ein Problem, ein Kommentar oder eine Frage?
Ähm, ein Problem in Verbindung mit einer Frage. Und zwar, ich hab mir jetzt ISDN angeschafft, hatte vorher immer so schicke Elsam-Modems und irgendwann reichen mir die 56K nicht mehr aus. Und dann machte der gemeine Gip, also diese tolle Fernsehwerbung wegen Highspeed mit T-ISDN.
Ja, weiter, weiter.
So hab ich dann auch reagiert, ich kriegte dann also dieses ganze wunderbare Paket, steckte die Siemens-Eisdorf-Karte dezentral beschafft in meinen Rechner.
Wie dezentral beschafft?
Ja, und ein Siemens-Werksverkauf.
Was eigentlich für was Siemens die Abkürzung ist? So ist es meistens eigentlich nicht sinnvoll.
Auf jeden Fall, das ist toll. Dann machen wir jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen Kanalbündelung. Das Ding legte permanent auf, und ich rief dann also bei Tee online an, und die sagten mir, das tut uns furchtbar leid, aber wir bieten das nicht an.
Willst du porten kein ESDN, oder wie?
Also das wohl, aber keine Kanalbündelung.
Aber ich hab jetzt grad gelesen, das war glaub ich auf dem Heiseticker, dass es jetzt einen Pop gibt, der sowas anbietet. Pop, genau, Pop Game, glaube ich, ist es www.pop.de.
Das war das Problem jetzt zu der Frage. Kann mit der iSurf-Karte und dem DFÜ-Netzwerk von NT zwei separate Verbindungen gleichzeitig aufbauen? Aber dann kriege ich natürlich auch durch diese dämliche Variable-IP-Adressenvergabe zwei verschiedene IP-Adressen. Und da greift ihr immer nur auf die erste Verbindung zu, also auf die IP-Adresse von der erstgemachten Verbindung.
Deswegen willst du nicht NT benutzen für Netzwerken?
Sondern Linux zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber gibt's wo auch immer? Von mir aus wird unser Linux ein Tool.
Da gibt's IP-Chains, das kann das auch, glaube ich.
Ja, es gibt auch Kanalbindelungen, das ist ein extra Protokoll. Also man macht nicht nur zwei Verbindungen auf, sondern da gehört noch mehr dazu, um Kanalbindung zu aktivieren. Und da gibt's sicher auch für Windows Tools, aber da können wir dir jetzt echt nicht weiterhelfen.
Aber ich kann also nicht aus zwei IP-Adressen irgendwie eine machen, die das dann wieder auf die zwei zerhackt?
Nee, na das Problem ist einfach folgendes. Du möchtest ja auch eine Verbindung dann aufteilen. Normalerweise, wenn du irgendwie FDP machst und möchtest dir jetzt Netscape-neue Version sorgen, dann soll das ja auch verteilt auf beiden Kanälen kommen. Und die haben aber verschiedene IP-Nummern, da kannst du also überhaupt nichts tun. Da möchtest du gerne ein Spezial-Kanalbündelungsprotokoll fahren, sodass die zusammen wie eine IP-Verbindung aussehen, eine ESDN-Verbindung gar, und dann läuft das.
Kann man da irgendeinen Provider empfehlen, der das qualifiziert anbietet?
Also Kanalbündelung. Kanalbündelung, ja, machen nicht viele eigentlich. Und in Deutschland liegt das vor allem daran, dass es auch kein Kunde normalerweise will, weil einfach die Telefonkosten ruinieren einen. Aber du kannst mal, wie gesagt, auf heise.de die E-Sledge-Newsticker gucken. Da war vor ein paar Tagen so ein Announcement, dass es jetzt einen gibt, der das macht.
Noch was anderes Dummes. Und zwar, ich kriege ab und an mal die Datenschleuder, die bestelle ich mir originellerweise im BTX.
Wow, ey.
Du bist es.
Ja, ich weiß, ich bin pervers.
Ich befehle mich gern.
Halt, halt, halt, halt. Ich komme ja wieder nicht mit. Was ist denn ein Datenschleuder? Was ist BTX?
BTX heißt Bildschirmtext. Das ist der Vorgänger von T-Online. Ja, als T-Online noch langsamer war, war das BTX.
Ja, oder Datex J.
Die Datenschleuder ist unsere Zeitschrift, unser Magazin. Ein wissenschaftliches Fachblatt für Datenreisende.
Das habt ihr noch auf so einem BTX-Teil?
Nein, über BTX kannst du deine Adresse hinterlassen, dann wird dir das zugemählt.
Also per Telefonrechnung abgebucht.
Das macht die Posto nicht mehr lange, insofern musst du dir bald was anderes überlegen.
Ich hab auch noch irgendwo so eine Hackerbibel Version einprungen zu fliegen und da sind in den alten Datenschleudern immer Bestellfetzen und Mitgliedsfetzen. Und den Mitgliedsfetzen, den gibt's nicht mehr. Und das find ich schlecht, weil ich wollte schon immer mal bei euch beitreten, aber es gelingt mir irgendwie nicht und ich bin zu faul, da extra zu schreiben, um mir so ein Ding schicken zu lassen.
Ganz sicher?
Da müsste auf der Rückseite was drauf sein.
Der Mitgliedsfetzenlein, auf der aktuellen Datenstätte, auf die von vor fünf Jahren.
Ich kann ja einfach mal hier ganz eilig greifen, das ist hier die Nummer 57.
Also du kannst auch per Mail dir den zuschicken lassen, würde ich mal behaupten. Ich wollte gerade fragen gehen. Office.rccc.de.
Aber 57 ist glaube ich schon drei Jahre alt, das war bevor die Fahrausstattung...
Einfach hier einer aus dem Schrank gegriffen. Da kann man auch klicken, ansonsten ist das glaube ich Office.rccc.de.
Die haben auch Rechner da beim Chaos Computer Club.
Bist du aus Berlin? Ja. Dann komm doch vielleicht einfach mal beim Club Discordia vorbei auch.
Das kann ich mal machen.
Ich bin nicht mehr aktualisiert im Netz.
Der hat sich auch nicht viel geändert an der Adresse.
Nee, an der Adresse nicht, aber hier sind seit irgendwie seit 1998...
Ja, da stehen ein paar alte Daten. Tim ist ziemlich überbeschäftigt im Moment. Ja, da muss er durch.
Vielleicht kann ja mal der Cold-User mit dem Windows NT4 System hier anrufen und erzählen, welche Tools er benutzt, um von seinem Windows OSR exakt zu machen.
Es gibt übrigens auch einen NetCut für Windows. Also für alle, die echt nicht auf Linux oder so was oder Linux wirklich umsteigen wollen. Es gibt so ein paar nette Tools auch unter Windows. Teilweise nur Windows NT.
Habt ihr immer noch keinen Winner entdeckt, der da eure Aufgabe knackt?
Na ja, Aufgabe, also sagen wir mal so, Aufgabe haben wir auch nicht wirklich so formuliert, weil...
Doch, root werden.
Genau.
So, wollen wir noch hacken in Telefonvermittlungsstellen diskutieren? Doch, sehr gern. Wenn Ralf noch dran ist, können wir das.
Ja, Vermittlungsstellenanlagen, Frage. Habt ihr eine Ahnung oder kennt ihr Leute, wie man da rankommt, Daten auslesen kann, beziehungsweise verändern kann? Jetzt, ich meine, legal ist das nicht ganz, aber das wäre schon halbwegs legal. Also ich setze mich da jetzt nicht hin und würde da irgendwelche Datenbänke verändern.
Du willst das sozusagen mit dem ethisch korrekten Hacken?
Ja, ich würde nur erstmal nach Software oder beziehungsweise nach Literatur fragen.
Die Software kriegst du schon mal überhaupt nicht. Das sind alles Trade Secrets. Also wenn du einen legalen Grund hast, dann ist das gewöhnlich, weil du für eine Firma arbeitest, die so einen Teil im Keller hat.
Zum Beispiel.
Und dann kannst du über diese Firma bei Siemens mal anrufen oder bei Alcatel oder wer eure Anlage gebaut hat und dir was zuschicken lassen. Aber so richtig offen sind die da nicht?
Nee, die sind nicht offen, weil die sagen nur, du kannst probieren und wenn du es schaffst, dann ist gut und Job winkt und sowas. Aber deswegen bin ich immer auf der Suche nach irgendwelchen Leuten, die da mehr Ahnung haben.
Warum musst du an so einer Telefonvermittlung ran?
Wissen tue ich gar nicht. Ich hab mich vor einer Weile mit einem von Siemens da ziemlich weit oben unterhalten und der war eben der Meinung, dass die Vermittlungsstellenanlagen sehr, sehr sicher sind.
Du möchtest jetzt das Gegenteil beweisen.
Genau, reicht mir.
Also ich glaube, dass sie sehr, sehr sicher sind, das kann man schon eigentlich erst mal so sagen, aber es gibt keine absolute Sicherheit. Wenn die Firma Siemens sagt, oder die Telekom sagt, unsere Vermittlungsstellen sind sicher, dann heißt es noch lange nicht, dass sie auch wirklich sicher sind.
Der Meinung war ich ja auch, deswegen blöds ist das Problem jetzt irgendwie hauptsächlich überhaupt erst mal an Literatur, welche Protokolle machen die dort überhaupt?
Also die Protokolle, die diese Vermittlungsstellen untereinander sprechen, sind SS7, Signaling System Nummer 7. Da findest du Informationen bei der Etsy, da kann man sich sämtliche Standards downloaden. Und ich fürchte Dokumentationen für Vermittlungsstellen gibt es nicht wirklich. Also da hast du keine andere Chance als dir irgendwo mal eine zu kaufen. Und die dazu gehörte Dokumentation und die Schulung. Also ich kenn einige Leute, die probiert haben, an diese Dokumentation ranzukommen. Das geht einfach nicht.
Also ich glaub, wenn sie im Internet veröffentlicht werden, werden sie auch nicht mehr sicher, oder?
Na Moment, das ist irgendwie der Kardinalfehler, den alle Leute immer machen. Man sagt bei Sicherheitsüberlegungen grundsätzlich, dass man nur den Sachen traut, die veröffentlicht wurden und wo trotzdem keiner ein Problem gefunden hat. Denn man kann immer behaupten, es ist sicher, wenn ich irgendwie in einer Truhe einschließe und die irgendwo im Atlantik versenken und keinem sage, wo das ist. Aber es hat sich rausgestellt, dass ich immer wieder Leute finde, die einfach echt zu viel Zeit haben und rumlaufen und darum tauchen. Die finden dann deine Truhe. Und bei Siemens konkret ist das jetzt so, da kann ja mal einer in Rente gehen und der ist sauer über seine Bezüge und der rückt dann mit der Dokumentation doch raus. Und deswegen, die einzige Sicherheit, die es überhaupt geben kann, ist, wenn man vollständig dokumentiert, wie die Sachen aufgebaut sind und funktionieren und man gibt es den besten Leuten, die sich damit auskennen und die finden kein Problem, dann ist es sicher.
Weil ich ein bisschen was gelesen hatte über das sogenannte Blue Boxing, das war glaube ich damals noch bei den analogen Vermittlungsstellen, dass sie sich dann über AT&T oder was weiß ich eingewählt haben und dann meinetwegen hier in Deutschland kostenlos telefoniert haben beziehungsweise Daten dann hin und her geschickt haben.
Naja, das ist alles schon ein bisschen geschätter. Also das Telefonnetz ist mittlerweile glaube ich in Deutschland komplett digitalisiert und das ist alles nicht mehr ganz so einfach. Haben wir deine Frage erstmal soweit beantwortet? Danke Ralf.
Tschüss. So, wir haben mittlerweile neul Uhr.
Wir haben auch jemanden, der wirklich bemerkenswert viele Exploits probiert hat.
So, so klingt das Chaos Radio akustisch. Wir haben noch ein stündchen Zeit und wechseln jetzt so langsam von den Sachen, die man so braucht zu den kleinen Geschichten, was man erlebt im Leben, wenn man diese ganzen Werkzeuge einsetzt. Wir können natürlich weiterhin anrufen hier im Blue Moon bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club, mit Andreas, Felix, Jan und Frank. Unter 931 77 97 110. Ich sag's gleich. Die Jungs werden immer so ein bisschen unwirsch, wenn man so ganz banale Fragen stellt, wie, also wie richtig jetzt, was ist ich, meine Internetseite ein oder was ist HTML oder wie schreibt man HTTP oder sowas. Also denkt euch lieber ganz schwierige Fragen aus, wo sie so richtig kotzen müssen. Ihr könnt das Ganze auch verfolgen als Live Audio im Netz unter www.fritz.de und dann durchklicken. Dort zu finden auch der WeChat, wo Felix von den CCC Leuten auch fleißig zurückschreibt.
Du kannst auch schnell tippen.
Ja, das zudem.
Ja, ich wollte immer noch meine Glückwünsche.
Warte, dass wir noch eins kurz sagen, weil das ist relativ wichtig immer, weil das wissen nicht viele Leute. Wenn man jetzt die letzten zwei Stunden verpasst hat, man kann sie morgen als Real Audio oder MP3 auch bei Fritz im Netz wieder abrufen. So, ich bin jetzt fertig. Aber dann sag mir doch jetzt noch mal, was macht ihr mit den Tools und was erlebt man da so? Auf was stößt man da so?
Die App und Stories wollten wir noch erzählen können.
Genau, erst mal ist noch kurz unser Hacksport einmal der Sportbericht erstattet.
Ja, Sportbericht erstattet. Das ist doch live, man. Wir müssen hier berichten, wenn Tore fallen.
Dann sag ich noch mal kurz vorweg, es wurde sozusagen eine Hacksport-Aufgabe gestellt, nämlich einen Rechner in Hamburg zu hacken. Und wie viele Leute hast du das verfolgen können? Haben sich da jetzt schon dran versucht?
Ja, so durchaus einige. Vielleicht eine Handvoll, die tatsächlich nennenswerte Energie entwickelt haben. Zum Beispiel haben wir jetzt hier jemanden von NetServ, der tatsächlich Exploits auf so ziemlich Alben, was wir da gelaufen haben, probiert hat. Wir haben da FTP, wir haben da auf HTTP einen Exploits, sogar auf X, haben wir einen Buffer-Overflow-Attempt gesehen. Es gibt jetzt auch jemanden, der mittlerweile eine ETC Pass-WD gefunden hat und ein Passwort namens ccc-school rausgefunden hat. Nein, das ist nicht das richtige Passwort.
Also ich nehme an, das waren alles Fallen, die er eingebaut hat.
Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz, da ist gerade der Begriff Buffer-Overflow gekommen. Es ist also so ein, glaube ich, der Hauptfeind des Systembetreibers oder so was oder der Hauptfeind des Betriebssystems, so ein Buffer-Overflow. Das heißt, da funktionieren einige oder die meisten der Exploits drauf. Das heißt, ich verbinde mich irgendwie zu einem Rechner, meinetwegen über den Port FTP und schicke ihm dann irgendwie was ganz Unklares. Also ich sage da nicht irgendwie gibt es mir ein Verzeichnis oder lade mir zwei XYZ-Down, sondern ich sage irgendwie krrp, so. Und dann kann es der FDP-Rechner vielleicht irgendwie, kriegt er das einen falschen Hals und sagt, und hey, du bist jetzt gut, mach was du willst. Kann man das so im Groben mal klären oder noch was dazu zufügen?
Naja, die schönsten Beispiele sind immer E-Mail, weil das ist einfach deswegen so schön, weil eine bestimmte Firma aus Redmond so Werbung damit gemacht hat vor mehreren Jahren, dass sie jetzt ein tolles E-Mail-System auf den Markt bringen würden namens Exchange, was sie einfach mit allem getestet haben, was im Netz unterwegs ist. Und dieses System hat einfach in der ersten Sache, die man macht, wenn man mit einem Mailserver redet, hat es einen Wafferoberflur gehabt. Und als das gefixt wurde, haben sie in der zweiten Sache, die man mit einem Mailserver macht, einen Wafferoberflur gefunden und seitdem hat keiner mehr Lust mit Exchange zu reden. Deswegen Leute, Finger weg von Microsoft Produkten. Und gerade E-Mail ist halt ein Problem, weil da kann man auch so Zeitbomben legen, die gar nicht beim Angriff direkt explodieren, sondern später, indem man Leuten, die einen richtigen Mailserver fahren, wie sagen wir Q-Mail zum Beispiel, solchen Leuten schickt man eine Mail, die intern allerdings Mime Informationen enthält. Das ist ein Standard zur E-Mail-Ablage. Da kann man Strings vergeben, man kann Namen vergeben für Sektionen. Und wenn diese Bezeichner zu lang werden, dann kann man in schlecht geschriebenen Mailclient, wie zum Beispiel Outlook hat an der Stelle überzeugt, kann man beim Lesen der Mail zu einem Absturz führen. Oder man kann auch Code ausführen. Und diese Mail kann dann der User einfach auch nicht löschen, weil sobald sie geholt wird, stürzt schon der Client ab. Das heißt, er kann erst mal gar nicht mehr Mail lesen, bis er seinem Provider unter peinlichen Schweißausbrüchen erzählt hat, dass sein Mailclient immer abstürzt. Und deswegen, das sind Buffer Overflows, das ist so die häufigste Methode, um einen Rechner einzubringen. Und vor allem, was man halt nicht unterschätzen darf, ist, dass auf manchen Rechnern eben das mit den Sicherheitsbeschränkungen nicht so richtig gegeben ist, wie unter Windows 98 zum Beispiel, da gibt es irgendwie gar keine Beschränkungen, da darf jeder alles. Und unter NT läuft natürlich die Exchange auch mit Vollzugriff. Das heißt, wenn man da schafft, Code auszuführen im Exchange-Raum, dann hat man halt komplett Zugriff auf den Rechner. Deswegen, da muss man eben nachdenken, bevor man solche Services schreibt. Da gibt es eben das User-Konzept, dass solche Dienste dann am besten als Niemand laufen. Oder unter Unix versucht man dann noch, die einzuschränken auf einen bestimmten Teil der Festplatte. Die können also nur bei Daten rumlesen oder schreiben, die eigentlich nicht wirklich was zu bedeuten haben. Sowas ist also seit Jahren erforscht und man sollte auch nur Dienste benutzen, die das anbieten.
Wir können ja vielleicht fürs Protokoll nochmal drei Worten erklären, wie Buffer-Overflows wirklich funktionieren. Was da in der Regel passiert, ist, dass man einen Buffer auf dem Stack hat. Zwischen den Variablen auf dem Stack liegen ja immer die Return-Adressen der Funktion. Wenn man einen Buffer reinschreibt und über die Grenze des Buffers hinaus schreibt, schreibt man auf die Return-Adresse. Wenn man diese Return-Adresse wiederum auf den Buffer zeigen lässt, dann kann man den Code, den man da reinschreibt, anspringen. Es gibt natürlich auch Tools, die solche bekannten Buffer-Overruns suchen. Das erste, was es da gab, ist Zatan, das ziemlich viele Security-Scans gemacht hat. Und in letzter Zeit sehr beliebt ist Nessos. Also Nessos ist schon ziemlich komfortabel. Da muss man nur noch eine IP-Adresse eingeben und draufklicken. Also schon fast gar kein Sport mehr. Aber das findet relativ viele von diesen Buffer-Overflows, auch viele von den klassischen Lücken, findet auch die ganzen Denial-of-Service-Attacken und so weiter und so fort.
Man sollte dazu sagen, dass diese Tools nur bekannte Buffer-Overflows finden. Also was es noch nicht gibt, was eine echte Marktlücke wäre, ist ein Tool, was sich bestehenden Quellcode für irgendein Server-Produkt anschaut und dann sagt, hier ist programmiert worden, das sieht aus wie ein Buffer-Overflow, das gibt es noch nicht. Also Nestos findet auch nur Probleme, die erstens gefunden wurden, wo zweitend jemand Lust hatte, das in ein Plugin zu coden und wo dieses Plugin dann auch noch in Nestos eingebaut wurde und das Release-Buster auch noch bei dem User installiert werden. Da ist also Zeit vergangen dazwischen, in der Leute auf dem Web schon, auf dem Internet irgendwo die Sache exploiten konnten. Deswegen nicht verlassen auf so eine Tools, die sie natürlich trotzdem anwenden, aber das darf nicht alles sein.
Sportberichterstattung. Lieber Othello-User, dir ist kein S&TP-Befehl. Vielen Dank für die Überachtung aller Sicherheitsmaßnahmen.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu Passwort-Geschichten. Früher war ja auch, ich glaube, das hat man in den Filmen 23 gesehen. Ich glaube, dass sie das nicht richtig in Erinnerung gehabt haben. Die haben da versucht, auch Passworte zu erraten. Das heißt, sie haben dann einfach viele Varianten durchprobiert, ganz, ganz viele, bis es dann irgendwann mal gepasst hat, bis sozusagen sich der Schlüssel im Schloss umdrehen lassen konnte. Wenn ich jetzt so einen Zugang habe über e-Mail, also über POP3, zum Beispiel, bei das Protokoll, kann ich da einfach auch Passworte ausprobieren. Oftmals ist es so, dass man dann von dem Server gleich rausgeschmissen wird und es geht bei den Systembetreibern Alarmglocke an, wenn man da irgendwie fünfmal hintereinander ein falsches Passwort oder der Zugang wird gesperrt oder sowas. Da gibt es ein paar Varianten. Wie man so was umgehen kann, ist, indem man schafft, irgendwie Zugang zu dem Rechner zu kriegen und dann die Passwortdatei runterzuladen. Also auf jedem Rechner ist ja irgendwo, also jedem Rechner, der irgendwie verschiedene Benutzer den Zugang erlaubt, hat es eine Passwortdatei gespeichert. Bei Unix zum Beispiel ein slash etc slash pass-wd, das ist ein ganz Bekannte. Und wenn man die schafft, sich anzusehen oder runterzuladen, dann kann ich die sozusagen, also sind die Passwörter natürlich verschlüsselt drin, also nicht im Klartext, sondern verschlüsselt. Und dann kann ich die zu Hause auf meinem superschnellen Pentium 2 mit so und so viel Megahertz, kann ich die dann ganz schnell entschlüsseln, indem ich nämlich einfach alle Varianten ausprobiere.
Das ist allerdings auch schon wieder alt, weil inzwischen wird das schon geshadowt. Also die liegen da nicht mehr in verschlüsselten Formen vor, sondern die liegen in einer anderen Datei und können daher auch nicht so einfach gelesen werden.
Richtig, aber wenn ich jetzt angenommen, ich habe jetzt durch irgendeinen Exploit geschafft, root zu werden, dann will ich ja nicht einfach irgendwie die Festplatte formatieren. Das ist ja langweilig, sondern ich will möglicherweise erst mal noch irgendwie das richtige Root-Passwort haben, dass ich mich da praktisch offiziell einloggen kann. Auch dann will ich natürlich auch das Root-Passwort erst mal ausverkaufen.
Genau, zu Sniffern übrigens noch. Es gibt natürlich dann immer gute und weniger gute Netzwerkdienste und NTU überzeugt an dieser Stelle damit, dass sie die Passwörter in relativ schlecht verschlüsselter Form beim File-Sharing ständig übers Netz blasen. Das heißt, man muss sie einfach ans Netz hängen, nichts tun. Das heißt, man ist auch nicht sichtbar im Netz. Man muss einfach nur ein bisschen mitloggen. Da gibt es ein nettes Tool namens Loftcrack bei l0pht.com wird das geschrieben. Kann jemand mal gucken. Das ist ganz verbreitet eigentlich und kann ich auch allen Leuten nur empfehlen, das mal zu benutzen.
Genau, das ist ja wie sicher euer Windows.
Gerade mal Zeit für ein bisschen Mitleid. Dex ist dran aus Berlin.
Und kriegt Windows nicht installiert?
Nee, Dex Homepage wurde mal gehackt. Hallo Dex.
Ich weiß nicht.
Hast du zufällig die Webseite von www.bundeswehr.de? Oder von verfassungspfiltze.de?
Pass auf, ich war auf eurem Kongress gewesen.
Oh, schwerer Fehler in der Beziehung.
Richtig und da hab ich meine Homepage, meine tolle Homepage bei IRC-Float einfach mal so geupdatet.
Das heißt, du weißt jetzt genau wie...
Passwort-Sniffing funktioniert, genau.
Jetzt weiß ich ja natürlich. Damals war ich so blöd gewesen und hab die da einfach mal so schnell geupdatet.
Sag mal, bei welchem Kongress war das? Bei welchem Kongress war das?
Der letzte.
In Berlin, ein großes Schild hab ich da selbst hingehängt, da stand drauf, hier wird Sniffing vorgeführt. Damit meinten wir genau, dass man das, was du getan hast, nicht tun soll.
Aber was genau ist jetzt deiner Homepage passiert?
Ja, da sind Smilies gekommen, Texte wurden umgeändert und das Passwort konnte ich natürlich jetzt aufweggeschmeißen. Also da hat derjenige gleich mal mein Passwort umgeändert.
Die Smilies sind doch aber schön auf...
Auf hat sie meine Fernwartung gemacht, ja?
Update ist nicht mehr, ne?
Du hast vielleicht, wo wir jetzt gerade bei dem Kongress sind... Ja, also hattest du jetzt eigentlich eine Frage?
Wolltest du einfach noch verärgert den CCC hier anklagen?
Nicht anklagen, von meinem Grundein.
Nein, das ist ja nun wirklich nicht unsere Schuld.
Wir waren es nicht.
Wir schwören, wir waren es nicht.
Also sie selbst waren es zwar nicht, aber vielleicht waren es andere.
Also es waren ungefähr 500-600 Leute und einer von denen war es.
Genau, wir haben unter anderem Durchsagen beim Kongress gehabt, wie der Mann mit der IP-Nummer so und so kann sich sein GMX-Account abholen, oder der Hotmail-Account so und so sollte schnell sein Passwort ändern. Das ist durchaus mit mehreren Leuten passiert auf dem Kongress.
Also Dexto hast du auf jeden Fall jetzt ausgelernt, ne? Also in der Beziehung hast du da eine richtige Lehre bekommen. Du machst das nie wieder bei irgendeinem Kongress, wo CCC irgendwo steht.
Eigentlich am besten überhaupt nicht. Also versuchen sie sichere Verbindungen zu benutzen.
Ihr wollt einfach nur eure Bandbreite ausnutzen.
Ihr habt da ja wirklich, wie viel war das da gewesen?
2 MB. Großartige 2 MB, die einfach ständig dauerbreit waren, weil die Leute alle... Wir haben ja gedacht, dass die Leute von innen so viel klicken würden und dass das unsere Bandbreite töten würde, aber es hat sich rausgestellt, dass viele Leute von außen unseren FDP-Servicen gelutscht haben in der Stadt und dass das in Wirklichkeit die Bandbreite getötet hat und daraus haben wir gelernt und beim Kämpf wird der FDP-Servicen von außen nur ausgesuchten Fernwärtern zur Verfügung stehen. Da wird dann mehr Bandbreite zum Klicken sein.
Ja, es war auch einfach geil gewesen. Also, du konntest 8 MB Downloads gleichzeitig laufen lassen und dann noch einen FDP-Servicen laufen lassen.
Ja, Formelplatten werden jetzt auch zum Glück billiger und...
Da wird's genau, da wird's wieder einen großen FDP-Servicen mit einem großen Incoming geben für alle Leute, die sich immer noch überlegen, ob sie da kommen sollen oder nicht.
Matthias hat eine Frage. Stellen Sie es selbst, Matthias, ich weiß eh nicht, was es ist.
Proxycash, und zwar für einen normalen Heimeanwender, wenn man jetzt öfters E-Mails abholen will.
Was für ein Cash?
Das haben doch auch die Internetrechner.
Hat aber mit E-Mail erst mal nichts zu tun.
Na ja, doch, doch, doch, schon unter Umständen. Aber erzähl erst mal weiter, ja.
So ein Proxycash will ich mir zuhause einrichten, hab im Internet bisher noch nichts weiter gefunden dazu.
Dann kann ich dir, weiß jemand, es gibt so ein Programm, das nennt sich Webwasher. Kann der eigentlich auch cashen, weißt du das?
Nee, der kann nicht cashen, aber Webwasher, also wir empfehlen die Benutzung eines Linux-Rechners, da kannst du Squid drauf tun, das kostet dich genau gar nichts.
Es gibt aber auch für Windows mittlerweile freie Proxys sozusagen. Du weißt, was du mit einem Proxy machst?
Na, ich will ja die Seiten nicht ständig runterladen müssen, sondern bloß die neuen.
Die musst du immer noch runterladen, aber wenn du zweimal die gleiche Seite siehst, dann musst du halt nur einmal sehen.
Das ist deine Lieblings-Suchmaschine.
Alter, das hat jemand geschafft.
Sie wissen es nicht.
Wir überlegen bloß, was wir jetzt sagen, außer ist er nur der Linux, weil da ist einer dabei.
Also wenn wir dir jetzt sagen, wie man das mit Windows macht, dann könnte das jemand so interpretieren, dass wir der Meinung sind, man sollte Windows für sowas benutzen. Deswegen können wir dir jetzt schon aus ethischen Gründen nicht weiterhelfen.
Also es gibt, aber ihr sagt es gibt möglicherweise für Windows gibt es sowas. Man macht es auch irgendwo.
Hast du das schon gemacht, Matthias?
So die Suchmaschinen, die gängigen, Hotboard, Lycus und so durchprobieren.
Ihr könnt ja mal aus dem Chat hier vorlesen, ihr behauptet eine, es gibt bei www.windproxy.com sowas. Aber das habt ihr nicht von uns gehört, weil wir supporten kein Windows.
Aber das klingt ja schon mal gut, die IP.
Wir supporten kein Windows, alle Welt hat es, aber ihr supportet es nicht.
Ja, deswegen supporten wir es ja auch nicht, damit wir nur eine kleine Zahl an Usern.
Also Matthias, wenn wir im Laufe der Sendung hier noch weiteres rauskriegen, wo diese Dinger für Windows rumstecken, dann sagen wir es. Ja klar. Bleib einfach dran, ansonsten bringen deine Suchmaschinen auf Touren. So, mach ich mal. Also drei Stichwörter dürften genügen. Bye bye, tschau. So, eine hab ich noch, oder wollt ihr noch ein bisschen was erzählen? Dann machen wir doch noch mal was zu Musikcomputern. Markus aus Berlin hat angerufen, die 031-70-97-110.
Es ist ganz lustig zu hören, da sind anscheinend wirklich nur Freaks. Das ist ungefähr genauso.
Nein, nein. Pass auf, ich bin der Einzige, der nicht Freak ist. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Wir sind überhaupt keine Freaks. Wir können gar nicht mit der Maus umgehen.
Ich hab jetzt gar nicht versucht, meine Internetverbindungen herzustellen.
Ich lasse dir über die Finger von heute.
Meinst du, wir würden dich hacken?
Na wer weiß.
Also da reicht einfach mein Kenntnisstand nicht aus. Ich hab eine Frage und zwar zum Bereich Windows. Das wird dir sicherlich wieder mal nicht gefallen, aber das Problem ist einfach, dass es kein vernünftiges akzeptables Programm gibt, das MIDI Sequencing und Harddisk Recording unter Linux oder Unix macht und schon gar keine Treiber für spezielle Multi-IO Hardware. Das ist eins der größten Probleme.
Das ist ein allgemeines Dingsproblem.
Also es gibt schon Software, die das kann. Es gibt auch Multi-Track-Recorder inzwischen und das gibt es schon. Nur beim Treiber hast du natürlich verloren. Da musst du halt deinem Hardware-Provider die Ohren vollholen. Ich hab das gerade mit Matrox gemacht, übrigens, weil die bringen ja demnächst eine neue Grafikkarte auf den Markt und da sollten sie dann auch mal die 3D-Funktion erläutern. Das ist immer ein Problem mit Unix, weil die Leute einfach nicht einsehen, dass es ihnen was bringt, wenn sie das veröffentlichen. Und die Leute erklären dann so ganz halblaut, so ja, also aber wir werden es dann schon. Aber wenn wir das jetzt erklären, dann wird bestimmt der Treiber schlecht, weil das machen ja Hobbyisten. Also die Leute haben einfach Vorstellungen, die erstaunlich sind und die auch nur aus der Welt kommen, wenn ihr alle bei euren Hardware-Provider anruft und sagt, dass sie es mal offenlegen sollen. Also wir wollen gar nicht, dass sie einen Linux-Treiber machen. Die Leute haben zum Beispiel bei Creative immer rumgeheult, sie hätten gerne einen Linux-Treiber. Und was dann passiert ist, dass Creative einen Binary-Only-Treiber für ihre Soundblaster live gemacht hat. Und das hilft den Linux-Leuten so ein bisschen, aber Freebie ist die Leute überhaupt nicht. Also was wir eigentlich wollen, ist, dass sie ihre Dokumentation raustun. Und zwar alle, und zwar immer, und zwar bevor das Teil auf dem Markt ist, damit der Treiber fertig ist.
Also das konkrete Problem besteht eigentlich jetzt darin, dass hier mehrere Rechner stehen. Und wie kriegt man ein vernünftiges Netzwerk hin? Also ich sag mal, die Dateien, die da verschickt werden, sind WAV-Dateien. Die sind halt dementsprechend einfach riesig groß. Also dass man halbwegs komfortabel Dateien hin- und her schieben kann, ohne jetzt immer irgendwie den Umweg zu nehmen. Entweder halt, ich weiß nicht, erstmal einen Kaffee zu kochen, erstmal eine Stunde zu warten, bis da vielleicht 100 Megabit drin sind.
Mit einem 100 Megabit Netzwerk bist du da aber schon recht fix.
Weil die Frage ist, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob es reicht. Das ist das Problem, weil das sind halt Dateien, da ist dann halt irgendwie so ein Song besteht dann so aus 500, 600 Megabyte.
Kannste ja ausrechnen, mit einem 100 Megabit sind...
Also wenn du eine anständige Netzwerkkarte hast und das von deinem System richtig unterstützt wird, dann kriegst du bei einem 100 Megabit Netzwerk ungefähr 10 Megabyte pro Sekunde. Das heißt, für 600 Megabyte, da hängt das normalerweise an der Platte dann. Insofern, das ist aber auch keine Systemfrage, ob du da jetzt Windows benutzt oder nicht. Also du gleitest da grad ein bisschen ab. Also ob du jetzt Windows benutzt oder nicht, das wird auf jeden Fall ein Hardware-Limit sein, was sich da aufhält.
Dein Auto hat zu wenig PS ist die ganz gemeine Antwort.
Das heißt, selbst wenn es dann halt ein Linux-Programm geben würde, im Musikbereich, man würde jetzt komplett die ganzen Rechte auf Linux fahren, würde das auch nicht schneller laufen unbedingt mit der Datenübertragung.
Bitte sehr. So, haben wir noch jemand?
Nee, ist im Moment grad flauter. Ich sag einfach nochmal die Nummer 031-7797-110 für die ganz harten Probleme mit Rechnern. Gibt es Sportmeldungen neue?
Es gibt Sportmeldungen. Sebastian Schiller sollte vielleicht seine Mail-Adresse aus dem FDP-Client austragen, bevor er damit scannt.
Weil du sonst was tust, Andreas?
Na, seine Adresse verraten.
Ich trete nie datenmäßig in Verkehr mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club.
Stimmt doch gar nicht. Wir sind doch ganz lieb zu den Leuten. Wir erklären ihnen ihre Probleme.
Genau, wir sind ganz lieb.
Aber wenn jemand mit Outlook Express versucht, E-Mail-Flooding zu machen, was wir schon erlebt haben, dann müssen wir halt laut drüber lachen. Das gehört einfach dazu.
Genau, wir sind die lieben Admins.
Wir können vielleicht mal ein paar Beispiele bringen für böse Admins.
Genau, es ist eigentlich ganz lieber Admins. Das heißt, wir können mit sowas so locker umgehen. Also Admins, das sind für die, die das so verreuern. Das sind also die Systembetreuer, die dafür zuständig sind, dass irgendwie so ein System läuft.
Also meistens auch die altbekannten Roots.
Also in Häusern sind das halt meistens Hausmeister.
Die Hausbesitzer.
Nein, nein, nein, eigentlich schon die Hausmeister.
Also der Straßenadministrator läuft in der grünen Uniform rum.
Also ich meine, im Haus läuft ja auch der Hausmeister rum und schmeißt die Kinder vom Rasen. Ganz genau.
Ganz genau. Dann hatten wir auf dem Kongress, den wir ja schon erwähnt haben, gab es so eine nicht so schöne Geschichte. Nee, eigentlich kann man nicht sagen.
Ach, was hat nicht schön, ich fand die schön. Da spricht man noch seinen Enkeln davon.
Für den Betroffenen war sie vielleicht nicht so toll. Da ist nämlich eine schöne Hackaktion gelaufen. Beziehungsweise eigentlich war es gar kein Hack. Erstmal war es ein Hack und was danach kam, war dann eigentlich eher ein Crack oder ein Denial of Service. Eigentlich ging nichts über das Hacken hinaus. Bei einem Provider in Norddeutschland ist da jemand eingebrochen in das System und hat Sachen gelöscht, verfälscht, verhindert. Hat dann LK30 reingekriegt.
Also eine ganz böse Sache.
Das ist eigentlich ganz böse.
Das finde ich auch gar nicht toll. An der Stelle können wir das laut sagen. Wir sind nicht dafür, dass Leute Sachen kaputt machen. Aber das war gar nicht der Punkt an der Story, der nett war. Sondern nett war, dass dann plötzlich mitten in der Nacht die Polerei über uns in der Tür stand. Ein Mannschaftswagen fuhr vor, so vier Leute mit Uniform stiegen raus, haben sich da umgeguckt und haben uns eben gesagt, da sei ein Scan gewesen. Die Leute haben da schon gemerkt, dass bei ihnen da ihre Kunden plötzlich keinen Wettbewerber mehr im Netz haben. Und die haben also sofort polizeiverständig. Das an der Stelle auch legitim. Die kamen sofort bei uns vorbei. Und wir haben ein Problem gehabt, weil wir konnten ja nun schwer sagen, welcher IP-Nummer gehört, das haben wir nicht aufgeschrieben pro Rechner. Was dann passiert ist, die sind durch die Hallen gelaufen und haben so eine Stelle gefunden, da standen so ein paar Rechner und dann stand da ein bisschen Platz und dann stand da wieder ein paar Rechner und da hingen noch so ein paar Kabel in der Luft. Also war im Grunde so...
Und ein halb aufgegessenes chinesisches Essen.
Das war für die Polizei die Anhaltspunkte, herauszufinden, wer der...
Ja, das gibt mir auch eine ganz schöne Täterbeschreibung, wie männlich, 1, 80 Meter groß, mittelang, blondes Haar.
Okay, ich war's.
Das trifft ungefähr auf alle in diesem Raum zu.
Haben Sie die China-Falle mitgenommen zur Essanalyse?
Nein, aber das finden wir nicht gut, wenn Leute irgendwo einbrechen, Sachen kaputt machen in diesem Fall.
Also es hätte sozusagen gereicht, wenn er so... Hallo, ihr habt da irgendwie ein Problem. Genau.
Ich meine, das mit dem Hallo, ihr habt da ein Problem, das kann man auch ganz subtil machen. Das ist bei gewissen Zeitungen mal passiert. Da standen halt so winzige, so ein bisschen sinnverändernde Korrekturen im Text vorgenommen worden. Sowas kommt mal vor, das merkt man dann nicht direkt. Aber die Zeitungen merken das dann schon irgendwann. In dem Fall ist eine direkte E-Mail an einen Administrator angesagt. Und das ist das, was wir empfehlen an der Stelle.
Genau, damit kann man sich auch unnötig Ärger vom Halt schaffen. Genau. Und sagt so, hallo, ich war irgendwie bei euch drinnen, weil das und das. Und korrigiert das doch mal. Patch, das fixt das oder wie auch immer.
Aber auch genoßt, das kann irgendwie auch Probleme erst aufwerfen. Wenn die Leute jetzt...
Natürlich, denn das Identität ist irgendwie bekannt. Und das ist natürlich ein Risiko, mit dem man leben muss. Vielleicht anonyme E-Mails. Anonyme E-Mails oder sowas.
Gibt es sowas, wie die öffentliche Telefonzelle als E-Mail?
Also die öffentliche Telefonzelle ist absolut nicht anonym.
Ach stimmt, die kann man ja auch abhören.
Ja, nicht nur abhören, sondern auch. Das ist auch möglich.
Wenn man mit der Telefonkarte irgendwie telefoniert, dann ist das nicht mehr wirklich anonym.
Aber die Polizei braucht doch glaube ich 30 Sekunden oder so.
Nein, das ist Quatsch, die wissen bevor es irgendwie...
Das ist immer schön, in Filmen macht sich das gut, weil dann kann man so einen Countdown zeigen, und jetzt eke ich auf. Aber in der Realität ist das... Heutzutage ist das Telefonnetz digitalisiert, da gibt es irgendwie keine Delays.
Genau. Ein recht schönes Beispiel, wie das eigentlich im Ideal verlaufen sollte, das hat der Administrator von www.bundeswehr.de demonstriert. Wir haben von ihm letztens eine E-Mail gekriegt. Er hatte da so komische Einträge in seinem Blog-File gehabt, die auf einen Podscan hindeuten und Absenderadresse, AbsenderIP-Adresse, wäre unser Server gewesen. Und wir würden uns auch wahrscheinlich nicht so doof anstellen. Und da hatten wir die Gelegenheit, der Sache nachzugehen und haben festgestellt, nee, das war tatsächlich niemand von uns, wäre auch ziemlich dumm gewesen, macht einfach keiner. Und es muss also irgendwie anders gekommen sein. Wir haben dann, glaube ich, eine Theorie entwickeln können, wie das passiert ist, wie da jemand unseren Server benutzt hat. Es ist aber auch nicht wirklich tragisch. Ich weiß gar nicht, was wir dem irgendwie geantwortet haben, aber das war jedenfalls eine Variante für eine sehr, sehr korrekte Variante mit zusammenzugehen.
Habt ihr denn daraufhin noch mal ein bisschen mehr gesucht? Auf dem Bundeswehr-Server? Ob da wirklich ein paar...
Wir haben uns den nicht weiter angeguckt.
Das ist übrigens auch, da gibt es ein Gesetz dagegen. Wir empfehlen auch nicht anderen Leuten, sich den Bundeswehr-Server näher anzusehen als mit Netscape.
Das ist auch in Ordnung so. Jan oder Andreas, noch irgendwelche Administratoren-Geschichten? Wir können auch die Hörerfragen vielleicht haben.
Genau, ja. Also wenn ein Hörer jetzt zuhört und der hat einen coolen Administrator, der ihm irgendwie mal aufs Dach gestiegen ist, weil ein Port-Scan. Oder wenn irgendjemand in der Uni seine Aufgaben nur löst, weil die Professoren ihre Home-Direktories nicht so richtig sicher haben.
Die können anrufen unter 031 77 97 110. Wir haben aber jede Menge Hörer damit diversen Geschichten. Was hättet ihr denn gerne? Cisco Router. Michael aus Berlin, hallo.
Ich hab keine tolle Geschichte dazu. Erstmal, weil ich schon ein bisschen länger hier war, aber das ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Ich wollte fragen, wie kann man denn testen, ob der Cisco Router, ob man da reinkommt, weil wie man in Linus und so weiter reinkommt, das verstehe ich alles.
Dazu finde ich auch am Internet eine ganze Menge.
Oder auf den Datenschutz-CD.
Zwei Sachen dazu. Erstmal Datenschutz-CDs sind scheiße. Zu Cisco, ja, da gibt es Dokumentationen von denen. Es gibt auch eine FAQ dazu, die kannst du dir mal holen. Ansonsten, Cisco legt Wert darauf, dass man da einen Consultant fragt, der einen ungefähr 80.000 Dollar teuren Kurs belegt hat. Da gibt es ein Kursprogramm bei Cisco. Das heißt, die sind nicht so daran interessiert, dass jeder irgendwie von sich behauptet, Ciscos warten zu können. Du kannst bei Ciscos aber genau das Gleiche machen wie bei anderen Rechnern, nämlich einen Portscan. Und wenn es dein eigener Cisco ist, ist das auch in Ordnung. Dann stellst du fest, ob Telnetzugang erlaubt ist und SNMP. Das sind die beiden kritischen Dienste bei Ciscos. Das solltest du beides nur für innen erlauben oder am besten ganz ausschalten. Und ansonsten, wenn du mit deinem Cisco Port-Packet-Filtering machst, dann kannst du das auch mit einem Portscanner feststellen, ob das funktioniert oder nicht. Immer von außen genau. Cisco ist ja auch ein Netzwerkgerät. Und deswegen, das ist einer der Vorteile, warum wir alle Internetprotokoll benutzen, damit man dann mit den gleichen Tools alle Rechner scannen kann, egal welches System, was für eine Hardware. Nein, aber du kannst mit GCP dann feststellen, welche Pakete er durchlässt und ob er auf Telnet antwortet. Siehst du einfach an, wie du in Telnet bist. Und viel mehr Dienste hat so ein Cisco eigentlich nicht. Die haben noch zwei, drei Probleme gab's da, so eher Privacy-Probleme, dass Cisco auf Netzwerken lauert, welche, wie es er hat und so.
Also da gab's noch die Geschichte mit dem Cursor hoch und du sagst...
Es gab da einige Probleme. Ja, deswegen sag ich Telnet am besten ganz ausstellen. S&MP wird auch immer wieder gar missbraucht.
Man sollte vielleicht auch, wenn man tatsächlich ein ernsthafteres Interesse daran hat, Bug-Dreck lesen. Da kommen auch die Security-Announces von Cisco. Ich erinnere mich, dass es bei Ciscos auch ein Buffer-Overflow-Problem gab. Also ein reingesprächbares Problem. Und was mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit das Problem war, das dazu geführt hat, dass die Amerikaner bei den GATT-Verhandlungen die Position der Europäer schon vor den Verhandlungen kannten.
Man sollte vielleicht an der Stelle den Leuten mal die Angst davon nehmen, irgendwelche Routern zu analysieren. Das ist genauso eine Kiste wie der PC mit Linux drauf. Das ist halt auch eine Hardware mit einem TCP-Stack in Software. Das ist nichts Magisches und Cisco ist nicht irgendwie anders. Den kann man genauso betrachten wie ZX81 in der Ecke. Also das ist einfach auch, das ist jetzt kein Unix, sondern das ist ein Realtime-Betriebssystem, was Cisco da benutzt, aber das ist letztendlich die gleiche Abstraktion, die man da benutzt. Da machst du einen Nmap drauf und dann ist gut.
Na gut, also das mit dem TCP dann, das ist schon glaube ich dann der Trick, weil ich habe eben keinen Lockfile. Das war mein Problem, dass ich ja nicht sehe, ob was drauf ist. Also ob ich durchgekommen bin oder nicht selber.
So, alle anderen Anrufer müssen sich noch ein bisschen gedulden, weil wir müssen erstmal wieder so ein paar Nachrichten machen. Gibt es noch kurz was zum Sport, Andreas?
Es gibt noch ein Sport-Update, und zwar gibt es die ersten Statistiken. Wir zählen derzeit ungefähr 2600 verschiedene Hackversuche von insgesamt über 130 Hosts.
Wow.
Und vielleicht mag ja der eine oder andere, der daran beteiligt war, hier anrufen und ein bisschen was von seinen Erfahrungen erzählen. Wir sind Brennen interessiert. Und ja, ansonsten ruft an, hackt fleißig weiter.
Also auch wenn das vielleicht zu klingend irgendwie, also wir werden euch dann nicht auslachen. So sprechen wir ja irgendwie, wenn wir ja auch manchmal irgendwie gackern vor dem Licht vor sitzen. Keine Angst, haut euch ruft an.
Gut, das hebt euch dann vielleicht für die nächsten drei Minuten auf. Das Anrufen vielleicht noch ein bisschen probieren. Heben wir uns für die letzte halbe Stunde auf. So, jetzt machen wir ein bisschen Musik und melden uns da wieder zum Fritz Kurz Info. 031 1 1 ½ 1 Kurz Info.
Kriegsverbrecher. Das UNO-Tribunal in Den Haag hat bestätigt, dass Anklage gegen den jugoslawischen Präsident Milošević erhoben wurde. Er soll voraussichtlich wegen Kriegsverbrechen im Kosovo zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden. Die Anklage verschließt Milošević einen Ausweg aus der Krise über Verhandlungen. Anordnung. Wegen des Kosovo-Konflikts werden rund 120.000 Angehörige der US-Luftwaffe zwangsverpflichtet. Sie können weder in den Ruhestand gehen noch den Wehrdienst auf andere Weise verlassen. Eine solche Maßnahme wurde erstmals seit dem Golfkrieg getroffen. Absicht. Bundesgesundheitsministerin Fischer hat ihren Gesetzentwurf für die Gesundheitsreform vorgestellt. Cairn ist ein festes Ausgabenbudget von 250 Milliarden Mark jährlich. Das Gesetz wird von der Ärzteschaft und der Pharmaindustrie kritisiert. Einschränkung. Die Ansiedlung weiterer Fabrikverkaufszentren am Stadtrand von Berlin soll in Zukunft nach Möglichkeit verhindert werden. Darauf haben sich die Länder Berlin und Brandenburg in der gemeinsamen Landesplanungskonferenz verständigt.
Sport.
Manchester United hat am Abend die Champions League 1999 in Barcelona gewonnen. Die britische Fußballmannschaft besiegte den deutschen Meister Bayern München mit 2 zu 1. Die beiden Tore für Manchester fielen erst in der Nachspielzeit. Wette. Nachts gering bewölkt oder klar um 6 Grad. Tags meist sonnig, Höchstwerte bis 27 Grad.
Verkehr.
Uns liegen zurzeit keine aktuellen Verkehrsmeldungen vor, fahrt trotzdem weiter schön vorsichtig.
Feine Sache. Svenja Baumgartner mit dem Fritz Kurzinfo.
Damals, vor 20 Jahren, ganz in deiner Nähe, begannen irgendwie irgendwo...
Ach, was war das für eine Zeit? Das sollte eigentlich mal einer ein Buch drüberschreiben, oder?
Fertig.
Fritz präsentiert das fertige Buch über die 80er.
Wir wohnen am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, das bedeutet Chaos Computer und Club. Die drei sind hier vom Chaos Computer Club. Es geht auch um Rechner. Die drei heißen Andreas, Frank, Jan und Felix. Felix ist der, der hauptsächlich im V-Jet oder www.fritz.de slash V-Chat arbeitet und dort als Fefe auch relativ viele Fragen beantwortet. Und jetzt schmerzlich vermisst wird gerade eben. Ich hab's nämlich nachvollzogen. Wo ist dieser Fefe hin? Hat da gerade jemand reingeschrieben im Chat. Ihr könnt diese ganze Sendung auch als Live-Audio im Netz verfolgen. Wir haben vorhin jemanden dran gehabt aus Klausthal-Zellerfeld. Der hat gesagt, scheiß Qualität, aber immerhin besser als gar nichts. Wenn man in Klausthal-Zellerfeld wohnt, weiß ich, da ist Fritz schon mal ganz nett, wenn man das zumindest als Live-Audio kriegt. Und ihr könnt das Ganze als Re-Audio oder MP3 Morgan dann auch auf den Fritz-Seiten abrufen und euch die ganze Sendung nochmal einziehen. Und da viel lernen über Werkzeuge, die der Hacker so gewöhnlich anwendet und braucht. Sicherheitsgeschichten und viele Fragen auch von Hörern nochmal nachvollziehen.
Ja, nochmal die Adresse von unserem Angriffsteam, von unserem Opfercomputer. Das ist playground.linuxsecurity.de oder die 195.222.228.123. Playground.
Warte mal, du musst das nochmal sagen. Ich hab dir glaube ich das falsche Mikro gegeben.
Ah, ok, also nochmal playground.linuxsecurity.de oder die 195.222.228.123. Playground.linuxsecurity.de hackt das Ding auf, werdet rot und... ja.
Ihr Wind, Ruh und Ehre.
Genau.
Macht es wie viele andere Menschen, die das schon tun, ne?
Wir haben jetzt eine ganze Menge und es wäre supergut, wenn von euch mal jemand anrufen würde, hier im Studio und mal so ein bisschen berichten würde, wie er das von seiner Seite aus gesehen hat. Und ihr braucht wirklich keine Angst zu haben. Es gibt hier keine Fangschaltung. Wir hetzen euch nicht die Polizei auf den Hals. Wir sehen sogar noch nicht mal eure Rufnummer hier. Selbst wenn ihr mit der ISDN anruft. Das ist wirklich kein Problem. Ihr könnt ganz gefahrlos anrufen. Oder gebt euch einfach in die nächste Telefonzelle, wenn ihr euch wirklich nicht traut. Keine Angst. Ihr macht ja auch nichts Illegales an diesem Server, sondern es ist wirklich zum einen ein Spaßfaktor.
Man kann mal sagen, an Traffic sind bisher über 130 Megabyte angefallen, seit wir gesagt haben, dass dieser Rechner gehackt werden darf. Also da tut sich sogar was.
Das ist richtig. Wir sollten vielleicht die Telefonnummer ansagen, dafür, dass Leute anrufen können. 031 70 97 110. Diese Telefonnummer hat auch gewählt. Sicherheit Online Banking, auch ein Thema für euch?
Ja schon. Also das sind einfach Fragen, die auch immer wieder auf den Chaos Computer kommen. Die auch was mit dem Thema auf jeden Fall zu tun haben.
Hans hat diese Fragen.
Ja folgendes und zwar soweit wie ich bis jetzt HTTPS verstanden hatte, das war eigentlich, das sind ziemlich intelligente Systeme. Also gerade wenn der Schlüssel lang genug ist, wenn man irgendwie die internationale Version dann verwenden kann vom Netscape, wo sind denn da jetzt die Fallstrecke?
Bei HTTPS?
Ja genau, ich glaube, online Banking mache ich.
Ich meine, daran liegt es, damit steht es und fällt es ja, denke ich mal.
Also das Problem ist am wenigsten die gesicherte Verbindung dabei, das kann man so schon mal sagen. Das größte Problem ist, dein Rechner auf dem Backup Office oder NetBus installiert ist und mit dem man ganz einfach jeden Tastdruck ablesen kann. Das haben wir probiert, es geht. Also selbst wenn die Deutsche Bank zum Beispiel noch so ein schönes Java-Applet laufen hat und eine sichere Verbindung über auch von mir aus 256 Bit hat, es hilft alles nichts, wenn jemand einfach jede Taste mitlesen kann, die du eintippst.
Deswegen zum Online-Banken immer schön Unix-Systeme benutzen und bei den Banken abnerfen, dass sie keine Applets einsetzen, die unter Unix nicht funktionieren. Übrigens, hier nervt gerade der Martin im Chat tierisch ab, dass ich ansagen soll, dass die Real Audio Qualität toll ist. Also habe ich hiermit getan und jetzt Hör auf!
Also dann hat der Typik Chaosrad Zellerfeld jetzt hoffentlich auch besseres Programm.
Ja, das heißt, wenn ich also jetzt das Passwort, mein Passwort ein oder meinen Pin einhecke, das kann über irgendwie echomäßig von irgendwem, der kann sich da einklicken und das dann unverschlüsselt, so wie es einen Tippe abhören.
Nee, der kann sich nicht einloggen bei dir, aber wenn du auf irgendeiner Site irgendwas geholt und bei dir installiert hast, wo irgendein Trojanisches fährt, wie zum Beispiel Black Orifice installiert war, dann tut sich bei dir dieses Programm auf deinen Rechner und bleibt da auch erst mal. Und wenn der dich zufällig gerade abhört, während du da ein Online-Banking machst, dann kann der dich sehen. Und deswegen sollte man, wenn man schon tatsächlich darauf besteht, Windows zu benutzen, sollte man keine Sachen aus dem Netz holen, die man irgendwie nicht getestet hat mit dem neuesten Vien-Scanner, die man kriegen kann. Und übrigens auch keinen Vien-Scanner einfach aus dem Netz installieren und downloaden, da gab es natürlich auch schon Sachen. Deswegen die ernstzunehmenden Vien-Scanner-Hersteller machen PGP-Signaturen von ihren Sachen, nur sowas benutzen.
Und was wäre da besser, wenn ich das unter Linux mache? Jetzt dieses Problem, wie weit wäre das da besser?
Also unter Linux gibt es halt kein Back-Orifice.
Das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, am Möglichsten.
Nee, das ist keine Frage der Zeit.
Das ist einfach eine Systemarchitektur, die das nicht zulässt.
Also man könnte sowas schon schreiben, aber es könnte sich nicht systemweit so installieren, dass es einfach weiter läuft, wenn du den Rechner ausschaltest und wieder anschaltest, wie das unter Windows ist.
So, das kann sich automatisch dann so erinnern als Dämonen und da...
Ja, bei Windows 95 kann man das sogar so gut machen, dass du es auch nicht siehst im Taskmanager und so.
Und der NT.
Da gibt es ja Netboost. Das ist glaube ich das favorisierte Tool.
Da gibt es Netboost. Netboost ist auch nett, schön zum Fernwarten, ein bisschen größer als ein Backoffice. Also letztendlich, NT ist theoretisch schon sicherer, nur die Erfahrung zeigt, dass Microsoft es halt nicht hinkriegt, das richtig zu machen. Also da gibt es eine schöne Website, wo du dich informieren kannst, ntbugtrack.com. Also NT ist zwar theoretisch sicherer von der Architektur, aber sie haben halt auch dann noch genügend Bugs drin, dass es nicht weiter ins Tragen kommt.
Das heißt, unter NT gibt es auch Programme, die installieren sich übers Netz und fahren dann als Dienst mehr oder weniger hoch, wenn ich NT wieder neu lade.
Ja, aber die installieren sich nicht selber über Netz, sondern du musst da was ausführen. Oder ActiveX benutzen, das ist tatsächlich auch verboten.
Bitte schön, Hans.
So, jetzt noch eine Frage an euch als Spezialisten. Hendrik ist dran.
Also ich bin jetzt eigentlich in einem Gegenteil vom Hacker, der Doom User und ich wollte eigentlich mal fragen, wie das so läuft beim Hacken. Also ich meine, einfach als gut einloggen geht das sicherlich nicht so einfach. Wie läuft's denn jetzt so?
Also manchmal geht es sogar ganz einfach, als gut einzuloggen. Also das hört sich jetzt vielleicht lustig an, aber es gibt so... Na es gibt zum Beispiel, weiß nicht, es gibt einen Router, mir fällt jetzt der Hersteller nicht mehr ein, aber halt das ist über was Standard, wenn es den Kaufsten auspackt, dann ist da halt irgendwie das Passwort, das ist dann Admin und das Passwort ist Pass, also P-A-S-S-S. Und da steht halt auch eine Anleitung drin. Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die kaufen sich irgendwie 20 Stück davon und stellen dann ihren Firmennetzwerk auf und naja, ist schon keiner irgendwie, ist schon okay oder habe ich jetzt keine Zeit, mache ich nach dem Urlaub oder auf üblichen Ausschräden oder so.
Wenn man jetzt eine große Firma ist und sich über UGnet zum Beispiel anbindet oder unseren anderen großen Provider, die einem eine Leitung nach Hause legen, über die Telekom so alles aus einer Hand und die bringen dann auch den Router mit, dann hat dieser Router eben ein Default Passwort und da steht bei UGnet auf den Webseiten so, bitte ändern sie das. Aber da steht halt nicht groß auf dem Router drauf, das heißt die Leute ändern das eben nicht, weil ja, woher sollen sie das auch wissen?
Es gibt übrigens auch noch einen anderen großen Telekommunikationsanbieter, der ja seinen Zollsame als Standard Passwort verwendet.
Das kommt öfter vor. Naja, das ist üblich. Also SAP Standard Passwort ist das Datum der Erstinstallation. Also das machen alle Leute irgendwie so. Das hilft einfach nicht, sich von irgendwelchen Leuten irgendwas installieren zu lassen, ohne zu überprüfen, dass tatsächlich die Passwörter geändert wurden. Und was man auch nicht machen darf, ist zum Beispiel bei Telekom eine Mail an den Support schreiben, bei T-Online und sagen Ja, und mein Username ist so und mein Passwort ist so. Also nie sein Passwort irgendeinem sagen, auch nicht dem, der von der Telekom anruft und sagt, ich bin dein Freund. Sowas nennt sich Social Engineering, gehört auch zu Hacken übrigens. Also traditionell eben, ich bin von der Polizei oder ich bin vom Netzsicherheitsdienst und ich muss mal schnell ihren Server prüfen, wie komme ich denn hier rein? So was, da gibt es ganz tolle Geschichten, also traut keinem, traut uns auch nicht. Na, der Privatuser hat die gleichen Probleme, er fragt hier am Anfang nach einem Passwort und da kann man auch einfach Return drücken. Und was glaubst du, wie viele Leute da einfach Passwort Null haben?
Na, jetzt wollen wir mal einfach unter Linux, gibt man, weiß ich jetzt, A-Login und dann den Servernamen oder IP-Adresse ein oder wie läuft das?
Na ja, also, prinzipiell schon, nur das ist nicht die Art, wie man gewöhnlich einbricht, sondern wie wir vorhin erklärt haben, die Buffer-Overflows, da gibt es eben dann viele Programme, die irgendwelche Bugs haben, das kann man ausnutzen. Da würde ich dir mal dringend empfehlen, da gibt es einige FAQs im Internet, geh mal zu einer Suchmaschine deiner Wahl und frag nach Sicherheit und Buffer-Overflow und FAQ.
Aha, ok, dankeschön. Jo, bis denn.
Haben wir noch jemand?
Ja, Pensium.
Pensium?
Zwei.
Pensium drei vielleicht, was du da sehst.
Das ist aber ein scheiß Name.
Pensium zwei, na erzähl mal.
Fragen wir Jörg einfach.
Ach, schon weg, tschüss.
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Ja, warten wir einfach ab. Wir suchen ja immer noch jemanden, der den Hack auf die Adresse in Hamburg versucht hat.
www.nuxsecurity.de Genau, vielleicht ist da noch jemand nochmal dabei.
Ich geh jetzt hier einfach mal rauf. Hallo, wer ist da?
Hallo, hier ist Jan.
Hallo Jan.
Ja, ich war fast schon immer in einer Leitung, bin aber wieder rausgeflogen. Ja, dank der ISDN Technik macht's möglich. Und zwar ich folgen das Problem, ich hab mir Windows 98 draufgespielt, vorher 95 gewesen, hab aber nur 32 MB Arbeitsspeicher und seitdem ich jetzt den ganzen Internetzugang per ISDN baue, seitdem stürzt mein Rechner regelmäßig ab. Sobald ich den mehrere Stunden anlasse, zwecks Arbeit gehen und wegen dem Fax lass ich den ja laufen. Aber er schmiert dann beim Neustarten wieder ab, sobald ich eine Anwendung aufrufe, Internet oder Mehlkasten oder tralala.
Das fände ich jetzt unter Bashing, oder?
Nein, da kaufen wir erst mal ein bisschen mehr an, kaufen wir mal, dass das echt nicht mehr neu ist.
Das klingt ja wie nach defekter Hardware. Was macht man ultimativ als sicherste Möglichkeit?
Wie, dass dein Rechner nicht mehr abstürzt, oder?
Da sitzt ein Schalter locker, so klingt das, oder du musst mal Windows reinstallieren, das macht man sowieso normalerweise, wenn Windows mal wieder abstürzt. Also probier halt irgendwie, alle Hardware zu rütteln, ob du da irgendwas nicht festgeschraubt hast, ob deine... Dann ist das ein Windows-Problem, was du reinstallierst, dann ist gut.
Ja, aber erst mal ein paar mehr RAM-Chips einbauen, dann kann das sicherlich...
Eines Themen raucht nicht ab, weil zu wenig RAM drin ist, sondern sagt dir, Windows raucht auch ab, wenn zu viel RAM drin ist.
Und das hat die zweite Frage, die ich hier hin, wo möglich dazu hätte, ist, über T-Online kann ich mich leider kurz nicht mehr ins Internet einwählen, ohne meine zweite ISD-Anleitung herzugeben. Normalerweise kann ich T-Online starten, auf Internet klicken, und dann nutzt er die gleiche vorhandene Verbindung schon für den Internetzugang.
Wie, welche vorhandene Verbindung?
Na, ich hab vorher gehabt, unter Windows 95, die paar Tage, wo ich das genutzt hab, wenn ich dann vom T-Online rauf auf Internet klicke, nutzt er die bestehende Verbindung von T-Online, um zu gehen. Ich brauch also nicht meine zweite Leitung dafür hergeben. Mein Telefon funktioniert ja trotzdem noch. Jetzt ruft er mir permanent immer gleich...
Ruf doch da einfach mal bei T-Online an. Die wissen ja bestimmt einfach.
Das sind ja die Leute, die überhaupt keine Ahnung haben.
Ja, da sind es ja die Leute, die vielleicht sagen, ruf doch mal bei MCTC an oder sowas.
Nein, also pass mal auf, prinzipiell, das läuft in der Industrie so. Da gibt's einmal den Level-1-Support. Das sind die Leute, die irgendwie Student-Schilfkräfte, die keine Ahnung von gar nichts haben. Und die sagen dir, ja, wissen sie. Und wenn du da auf den Tisch heulst, weißt du, dann gehst du zu Level-2-Support, da sitzen die Leute, die irgendwie wissen, wie man Internet schreibt und dass man Netscape benutzt. Und dann gibt's den Level-3-Support, der kann ein Problem lösen. Und du wirst immer weiter verbunden, wenn du einfach dran bleibst, weil normalerweise dürfen die nicht auflegen. Das heißt, du bleibst einfach dran und da warst du voll.
Die sind mir ja da gekommen von wegen, ich soll meine DFÜ-Verbindung neu prüfen und tralala. Ja, so einzeln läuft der ganze Spaß ja auch. Nur es wird mir nix, wenn ich T-Online aufmachen muss.
Ich glaube, Jan, das ist ein Problem, das wir jetzt hier so aus der Ferne nicht lösen können. Zumal der CCC ja nicht so ein Anbieter ist, der zu sagen, stellvertritt für alle Anbieter, berät, wie man so ein Gerät installiert und das alles auf die Reihe kriegt. Ich tue mir leid, aber die Frage können wir jetzt echt nicht weitergehen, beantworten.
Vielleicht ist da noch jemand im Chat hier mit drin.
Ciao, Jan, vielen Dank. So, wir haben jetzt einen. Ray ist dran. Aus München.
Hey, das ist der Mann, der hier die meisten Angriffe gefahren hat gegen unseren Zauber.
Genau als er es erwähnt hat, ist mein Stream runtergefallen. Das fand ich ziemlich mies.
War keine Absicht.
Ja, hab ich dann auch gemerkt.
So, jetzt Ray, erzähl mal, was hast du unternommen, um diesen Rechner in Hamburg zu knacken?
Ich muss sagen, ganz lame. Erst mal, ich hab den Netzos drauf angelegt, weil ich den zufällig grad offen hatte.
Das war keine Absicht sozusagen.
Nee, das war halt grad da. Der ist schon mal ganz nett. Der hat halt dann die ganzen Services mal gezeigt, die so interessant sein könnten. Dann hab ich da mal draufgenett cuttet. Und mal gesehen, dass euer Sendmail sich dafür ganz lustig meldet. Dann waren wir auch klar.
Hey, wir sind stolz auf diesen Sendmail.
Dann war mir auch klar, warum der Netzo so schöne Meldungen ausgeglichen hat. Ich hab die alle schön eingetragen. So, die passenden Versionen und so, wa? So, will ich jetzt nicht unterstellen, aber sah so aus. Ja, und da hab ich noch so ein paar Tools, die ich auch noch im Verzeichnis so rumliegen hatte, zum Selbstauditing meiner Rechner. Braucht man ja genau Sekt, zufällig. Sagt da gerade jemand im Chat. Ausprobiert, aber war dann nicht so erfolgreich. Also ich unterstelle euch mal die Services, die die Versionen, da will ich vulnerable angeben, sind's nicht.
Das hast du gut rausgefunden, gut getimt vor allem.
Also Ray, du hast die Vermutung, dass sie dich da ganz böse auf die falsche Spur gelegt haben.
Nicht nur ihn.
Ja, nicht nur mich genau.
Wollen wir das jetzt mal so einfach wie möglich machen und versuchen zu erklären, was ihr da jetzt gemacht habt? Damit Ray wenigstens weiß, warum er jetzt daneben gelegt vorhanden ist.
Also es gibt da ein Toolkit namens, ja genau, Deception Toolkit. Das erklärt Andreas jetzt mal.
Genau, DTK übrigens von Fred Cohen. Fred Cohen ist der Erfinder des Computervirus. Der hat ein kleines Tool geschrieben, das so tut, als würden da Services auf diesen Ports laufen und das viele bekannte Sicherheitslöcher simuliert. Das heißt, man kann da hingehen, kann sich auf den Port connecten, kann so tun, als würde man einen Mail abschicken. Das funktioniert auch alles.
Und das Tool hat den Turing-Test bestanden.
Der hackt Ray gleich wieder. Also ihr könnt das ja mal ausprobieren, macht mal ein Telnet auf Port 25 und wenn man dann viz sagt, dann fragt er einen, was man denn für Kommande ausführen will. Also wir sagten, es gibt da mehrere Exploits-Simulator, die so tun, als würden sie funktionieren und einen ETC-Pass-WD zurückliefern. Da gab es offensichtlich auch Leute, denen dieses Pass-WD in die Hand gefallen ist. Die haben das gecrackt und da kamen dann auch Passwörter raus. Wir sind schwer begeistert. Und ja, das ist nämlich die Klasse 3 der Tools, die wir heute behandeln wollten, nämlich solche, die der Edmund verwendet, um den bösen Hackern auf die Schliche zu kommen. Und schon eins der fortgeschrittenen Varianten.
Kann ich zu diesem Tool gleich mal was sagen? Das fällt mir nämlich jetzt rein zufällig ein. Es gibt diesen BO-Faker, der sich gekringelt auf dem Boden, als ich ihn in Bucktrick gelesen hab, dass der BO-Faker einen Buffer-Overflow drin hat.
Ja, das war die Nachricht des letzten Jahres, würde ich sagen.
Also vielleicht vor allem noch mal langsam. Backorifice ist dieser...
Ist ein trojanisches Pferd.
ist ein trojanisches Pferd. Der BO-Faker ist ein Programm, das so tat, als wäre es Backorifice, genau mit dem Ziel, dass die Leute denken, da wäre ein trojanisches Pferd, sich dahin connecten, sich damit verraten. Leider hatte dieser Simulator auch eine Sicherheitslücke, die dazu führte, dass man die wieder ausnutzen konnte und sozusagen den trojanischen Pferdersatz wieder als trojanisches Pferd verwenden konnte. Schwer peinlich. Oh man.
Macht ihr das eigentlich den ganzen Tag so?
Genau.
Eigentlich sind wir ganz normale Leute.
So Ray, kann Ray jetzt eigentlich mit irgendwie euren Informationen von eben nochmal ran? Und was Neues ausprobieren?
Nö, da läuft einfach nicht viel auf der Kiste.
Ich hab nach DTK jetzt gerade mal im Bucktrack Arts Shop auf Perl gingen von da her.
Und mit Perl und da gibt's nicht viel.
Such mal auf Fresh Meat.
Ich hab nicht nach dem Tool gesucht, ich hab nach Exploitsch für das Tool gesucht.
Auch Tooltool.
Das wär's natürlich gewesen.
Da ist nicht viel zu holen, das sind alles Perl Skripte, die schon deshalb sicher sind, weil man unter Perl nicht so richtig viele Buffer Overflows hat wegen der dynamischen Strings. Außerdem läuft dieses Tool in einem Change-Route-Environment.
Ohne Binshell? Na, ohne Binshell.
Ohne Binshell, genau. Man sieht den normalen Fall nicht selbst, wenn man diesen hacken könnte, was nicht geht, weil es Perl ist, würde man auf dem Rechner nichts erreichen können. Das ist also relativ sicher. Dieser Rechner bietet im Übrigen auch noch mindestens einen Dienst an. Funktionsfähig allerdings, wenn man einen normalen Rechner hätte, der 20 Services hätte, wäre da bestimmt einer dabei, der hackbar ist. Also wir sind uns relativ sicher, dieser Rechner ist es nicht, aber dieser Rechner liefert auch wenig Services nach außen.
Also eine Sache noch, bevor jemand sagt, aber der CCC hat gesagt mit Perl, das ist nicht hackbar. Man kann doch mit Perl Sachen schreiben, die hackbar sind. Das kommt immer wieder vor, besonders CGI-Bins, wenn er gerne missbraucht. Glaub doch gar nicht irgendjemand jetzt. Genau, Shell Escape. Deswegen habe ich erwähnt, dass Chen Schrute übernommen kann, den Shell hat. Also mit Perl ist es zwar besser als in C, wenn die Leute so Anfänger sind, aber Leute, die die nicht programmieren können, können in jeder Programme ihre Sprache schlechte Programme schreiben.
Ray, hat es dir trotzdem Spaß gemacht?
Es war lustig.
Ja, doch, so ein Spaß, das können wir auch nur wirklich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Es war sehr lustig.
Okay, Ray, viel Spaß weiter in der München. Hörst du über Satellit oder den Live?
Es klingt über Satellit, es ist aber Real Audio. Also klingt die Format, wollte ich eigentlich sagen.
Also in München ist die Real Audio Verbindung wieder schlecht, oder was, der Live Stream?
Ja nicht, also je später der Abend, desto weniger die Leute, desto besser der Stream.
Na dann hast du jetzt noch 10 Minuten Zeit exakt die beste Qualität zu empfangen.
Wunderbar.
Die Leute brauchen ihre Bandbreite jetzt.
Die Leute gehen schlafen und die müssen morgen wieder arbeiten. Zu diesem Backorif, das wollte ich eigentlich nochmal loswerden, dass es teilweise sehr dramatisch ist, was da schon bei den Leuten installiert ist. Also es gibt irgendwie eine Statistik. Ich glaube, Andreas hatte irgendwie organisiert, dass bei einem Berliner Internetprovider fast über den Daumen oder...
Ja, es schwankte so. Je nach Tageszeit zwischen 10 und 30 Prozent der Rechner, die per PPP eingewählt waren, hatten sich mit Backorifys installiert und waren dementsprechend hackbar. Also es bedenkliche Ausmaße.
Also sollte wirklich jeder mal in seine Windows-Kiste irgendwie in sich gehen und vielleicht auch mal schauen, was da so alles drauf ist, was da vielleicht nicht hingehört.
Mein Gott, das artet ja richtig in Arbeit aus, wenn ich wieder zu Hause zu haben, oder? So, haben wir da noch kurz Zeit? Habt ihr noch Lust?
Ich sag dann ISA Port. ISA Port sagt euch nichts mehr.
Jetzt schon?
Ja, nee, ich hab das mal versucht bei der Postbank. Und die konnte mir natürlich nicht weiterhelfen, ob es überhaupt geht und so. Ja, die haben im Amiga halt über HTT, also Quatsch, über richtig, die haben ja über Browser. Und da frag ich mich, ist das jetzt genauso unsicher wie mit Windows oder so? Oder schmeißt sich da Kina mehr ran, weil das benutzt sowieso Kina mehr das Betriebssystem? Oder was meint ihr dazu?
Also generell hast du natürlich mit einem obskuren Betriebssystem größere Chancen, aber ich würde mir nicht sicher sein, dass du deshalb sicher bist. Normalerweise sind die Toots, die du verwendest, aus demselben Source kompelliert und haben dieselben Bugs. Wenn ein Exploiter dafür schreibt, weil er vielleicht gerade dich nicht mag, dann hast du verloren.
Ja, können die überhaupt was machen, weil du brauchst eine Fehlentransaktion, diese Tannen. Die liegen aber immer zu Hause. Ich meine, wenn die Kina hier klaut...
Das ist richtig, aber du weißt ja nicht, ob die Tannen, die du eingegeben hast, tatsächlich auch so bei der Bank ankommen.
Genau, da kann sich einer dazwischen schieben und so tun, als wenn ich mit der Bank rede und danach macht er da eine schöne Überweisung.
Nee, nee, der tut so und dir gegenüber, als wenn die Bank abgeraucht ist. Das ist ja vor allem bei der Qualität der heutigen Online-Banking-Applikation durchaus glaubwürdig, wenn du als Meldung zurückkriegst, interne Systemfehler 32. Sagt mir die Deutsche Bank zum Beispiel immer wieder, das ist nicht klar, ob das jetzt irgendwie... Und dann waren da ein paar Tannenzweck, da sollten wir schon mal nachfragen.
Jaja, stimmt, habt ihr recht. Ja, dann macht man das vielleicht doch nicht. Immer wieder doch zur Bank, frische Luft ist ja ganz geil. Nee, noch mal eine kurze Frage. Du hast ja schon Internet bei Corl und die hier, wo einiges von Mobil kommt, ja, die schieben mir immer... Also die erste Internetadresse, die man aufrufen kann, ist immer bloß ihre blöde Seite. Genau.
Na, machen die mit Absicht, ne?
Ja, das ist noch nicht klar, aber gibt es doch irgendwie einen Trick, das wegzumachen?
Na sicher, du machst irgendwie... Oder du schreibst einfach... Du benutzt Amiga, sagtest du, da gibt es eine... Genau, da kannst du eine Skriptsprache benutzen, um automatisiert eine Web-Anfrage zu stellen und die landet dann immer bei... dieser Fake-Seite und danach kannst du richtig rumsurfen. Ist doch ein netter Trick, das fand ich nett, als du das gesehen hast. Nervt dann natürlich ab dem ersten Mal, aber...
Ich finde das aber ziemlich eine Schweinerei irgendwie.
Schlaf schön. Ja, oder setz dich erstmal ans Netz.
Haben wir noch hier Minuten?
Nee, ich glaube, wir sollten mal beenden. Hier kommt ja gleich der Neidfahrt. Ich sehe schon jemand da draußen stehen und klopfen nicht, aber...
Müssen wir denn jetzt welche rausschmeißen, oder?
Nee, nee.
Müssen wir nicht.
Also jetzt einfach nicht mehr an.
Ruf jetzt einfach nicht mehr an. Vielen Dank allen Anerrufern, die hier angerufen haben. Wenn es noch Probleme gibt, der Mitstand der Sendung ist morgen ab Nachmittag wahrscheinlich so als ReaAudio oder MP3 bei uns im Netz oder www.fritz.de Ja.
Vielleicht sollte man noch sagen, dass die IP-Adresse für den Hack-Rechner ab jetzt nicht mehr zu hacken sein dürfte. Also vergesst es jetzt einfach.
Also der Rechner wird wahrscheinlich da bleiben, aber der Admin wird dann böse werden.
Also ab genau in... vorbei.
Und wie ihr euch denken könnt, weiß der Admin, was er tut.
Also das ist auch der Hinweis, ihr habt eigentlich keine Chance, oder wie soll ich das verstehen?
Nein, aber ab der wird es wieder mehr, weniger...
Dann wird einem wieder drauflos geprügelt, wenn was kommt.
Dann hat man keine Chance mehr.
Ich meine, da wird geprügelt und dann geguckt.
Gut, also das Beste ist, ihr vergesst die Adresse.
Untersucht euren eigenen Rechner. Hackt euren eigenen Rechner auf. Schraubt euch in der Lieblingskiste zusammen und hackt ihn mal auf, dann wisst ihr, was da passiert oder auch nicht.
Und kommt zum Camp und da könnt ihr die Sachen noch mal probieren.
Da könnt ihr auch Kontakt aufnehmen zum CCC. Oder auch ins Internet gehen, sagt dann noch mal die Internetinteressanten.
www.ccc.de.
Ganz einfach ist das. Vielen Dank Andreas, Felix, Jan und Frank. Wissen wir schon, was es in einem Monat ist? Chaos Computer Club.
Da geht es dann, glaube ich, um Unix. Um Unix wollen wir dann reden. Das war das Thema, glaube ich, was wir verschoben haben heute. Und da geht es dann um Unix. Sowohl Linux als auch BSD und System 5 und was es da alles Schönes gibt.
Kann man sich dann drauf freuen. Also in einem Monat, wieder der letzte Mittwoch am Monat, ist wieder CCC-Time. Vielen Dank euch, eine schöne Nacht und macht's gut. Vielen Dank auch Martin, der hier die ganze Zeit den Sound gemacht hat, die Musik gemacht hat. Mein Name ist Meg Warbeck, wir hören uns morgen wieder ab 4. Zu guten Zeit und ohne Rechner.